you
good morning everyone
we'll get started here sorry we're a
couple of minutes late
um
i'm gonna open up the public hearing on
house bill one zero zero one fn
uh before we do get before i do call the
first uh
witness we do have our blue sheets out
back for anybody that cares to sign in
under the bill whether they're for it or
against it if you wish to speak to the
bill we do have the pink cards uh just
fill it out and pass it forward
uh with that i will open the public
hearing on house bill 1001 and the chair
recognizes
i hope she's here representative
representative levesque
good morning
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee my name is representative
cassandra levesque and i represent
stratford for barrington
i'm here today to introduce hb1001
fn
girl scouts of the green and white
mountains is a non-profit organization
and is one of 112 councils chartered by
girl scouts of the usa
here in new hampshire and vermont the
council serves more than 10 000 girls
with the guidance of more than 3
500 dedicated and trained volunteers
they provide an accepting and nurturing
environment where girls build character
and skills for a success
these girls will develop qualities to
serve them all their lives such as
strong values social conscience and
conviction about their potential and
self-worth
through hundreds of programs offered
each year girls develop their leadership
potential in activities that enable them
to discover their values skills in the
world
connect with others in a multicultural
environment
and take action to make a difference in
their communities
ninety percent of the local girl scouts
participate
through traditional troops many
others participate through after-school
programs such as
[Music]
in day and residential camps
or
they through one week school vacation
activity centers
when girls could not participate in
person girl scouts stepped up and
brought the program to them through
virtual programming
girl scouts is an ever
and today's timely
top links include
science technology engineering math
adventure sports advocacy political
science dating violence awareness and
entrepreneurship
traditional subjects such as leadership
outdoor skills wildlife the environment
travel first aid disaster preparedness
and water sports are still available for
community service is a vital part of the
girl scout mission to make the world a
better place
girl scouts in our council alone
participate in thousands of hours of
service projects every year directly
benefiting their community this day our
country and the world
girls and girl scouts are doing amazing
things every day to discover the world
around them
connect with their interests and
passions and take action to make a
positive change in their world
however all of these wonderful
opportunities come with the cost
girl scouts are funded by a variety of
means and today you have the opportunity
to let them access another revenue
system
by the way of the girl scout decal plate
when an organization wants to use a tool
like the decal plates we want to make
sure that is a sustainable request
well thanks to active alumni which goes
back generations
the current membership and the future
members there is enough support to make
this very sustainable
thank you for your consideration and i
thank you any questions from the
committee
yep representative talerski
thank you representative levick and i'm
sorry if i missed this at the beginning
as i was getting settled um did you
share the number of girls that
participate in the
new hampshire program
yes
follow-up follow-up do you
have any idea of the number of alums
like former girl scouts that still live
in the state that may want to
participate in such a program i
do not but i could definitely get that
to the committee thank you i'm just
curious i imagine it's very large yes
thank you
further questions from the committee
i have one do you know the tax status of
the girl scouts uh
i believe it's on the
501c3
okay where you can find that uh
it is a non-profit so they will file
their taxes so
you will find it there no i appreciate
it important information uh the way the
statute is written
any further questions
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you um
representative for taking my my uh
question
would it be only alumni who would be
entitled to get these decals or would
anybody be able to get these decals
anybody would be able to get these
details uh decals uh
but alumni really
like to support girl scouts and show
that they are girl scouts whether that
they were a girl scout for like one year
as a brownie or
whatever age
so
thank you
[Music]
i see you in other questions but i do
have one more i just thought of uh it's
not required
um
to get approval for the plates but any
indication what they're looking for for
a design would it be the as simple as
the girl scout seal um
most likely i'm not sure what they're
looking for but it would most likely be
a simple design of like the girl scout
symbol
which is
a uh
trefoil which is the original girl scout
cookie okay thank you
any other
any other questions yeah a thin mint
i have no other pink cards uh nobody
else signed up to speak last call if
there's anybody else here that would
like to speak to this bill
seeing none i forgot my gavel but i will
close the public hearing on one zero
zero one thank you representative gagne
uh our next hearing as we get organized
for the rest of the day will be
uh at 9 30.
you
all right welcome back everybody um
being
934 i'm going to open up the public
hearing on house bill 1060 fn
authorizing the new hampshire
environmental educators to issue decal
plates
um as as always if you would like to
sign up on the bill for or against we
have our blue sheets out back if you
wish to speak uh just fill out a pink
card and send it forward
um speaking of pink cards i have none
and that includes from uh the prime
sponsor
uh it would is there a volunteer to
you're staying put
i need to fill up a card right
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee
my name for the record is
representative larry gagne from district
13 ward 6 in manchester
introducing house bill 1060 fn
authorizing the new hampshire
environment
environmental educators to issue the cal
plates
this bill authorizes the new hampshire
environmental educators to issue decals
honoring daring
jumping spider for multiple use motor
ah well thank you for introducing it are
there any questions representative
talersky
thank you representative
would you believe
that the prime sponsor of this bill was
also involved with the bill
last year
that a fourth grade class in hollis
worked with her to file
daring jumping spider the state spider
and this perhaps is her way to continue
the project with the
i did not know that representative
however
i don't doubt what you're saying is the
truth
any other questions from the committee
quick follow-up for the chair follow-up
do you know the new hampshire
environmental educators is that a state
division or department or is that a
independent organization that i'm not
sure i did look into it but i
i can't remember at the moment obviously
with with no other testimony today we're
going to have to do a little bit of
homework to make sure it meets all the
criteria for authorization so thank you
we will look into it
any other questions for representative
gagne
all right thank you sir
uh
last call anybody else wish to speak to
house bill 1060 fn
seeing that i'll close the public
hearing
our next one is scheduled for 10 house
bill 1492. i do apologize for some of
the downtime um but every time i try to
schedule 15-minute hearings i get in
trouble so
as the day continues we'll get a little
more efficient with the use of the
downtime
you
all right welcome back everybody um i'm
gonna open up the public hearing on
house bill 1492 fn
relative to decal plates for the new
hampshire council on the arts
uh as always if you wish to
take a position on the bill for or
against and sign in we have the blue
sheets out back
if you wish to speak to the bill please
fill out a pink card and send it forward
ah that being said the chair recognizes
representative yes good morning
the notice that i got last week said
that uh this hearing would be at 10 30.
i just happened to come early so if you
think i'm late i'm sorry that's okay
okay we're off to a little of rocky
starting so it's all good it'll all be
it'll all be calm now um
so i am francis nutter upham
hillsborough 33 nashua
um
i'm a painter an artist an art
psychotherapist
a supporter of the arts in many ways
one of my nashua constituents approached
me
last year and said
we should raise some money for the arts
she wanted to hit the
lottery money but i thought well that's
probably a heavy lift because it's kind
of
designated to education and i thought
that would be difficult
and then i looked up all of our vanity
plates and i noticed that there wasn't
one
for support the arts
um
you know there's the veteran ones the
the moose plate has done phenomenally
well
so i thought all right how would we
raise money and
who would
manage it and then i thought of the new
hampshire state council of the arts
because they already have in place
um
staff that
reads grants processes grants
and and they award uh money to
nonprofits so they are set up to handle
that kind of thing they also have the
bookkeeping that could handle that kind
of thing and they're statewide whereas
my
constituent in nashua was kind of
looking money just for nashua that's not
really fair we want to we're a state
you know i'm a state representative for
the whole state not just for nashua
so
i think
a decal plate for the new hampshire
state council of the arts would be kind
of awesome it would be fair and it would
be statewide
okay
sorry we're still getting used to these
microphones yes i know so thank you for
that um any questions from the committee
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative um
i just wanted to have you perhaps
talk a little bit if possible about the
amendment
because the amendment seems to be
different from the original bill that we
all received
is there any way that we could
um i i
i know
well i left it to
the legislative services to kind of put
the correct amendment on and i realized
that
normally you deal with just non-profits
and so this is
a little outside of that box because
it's a state agency but i was thinking
unlike other state agencies this one
is able to take donations they currently
already do take donations but any money
that they would raise from this decal
so
does that answer your question
i just wanted to clarify for the
committee that the original bill that
brings up a whole new section called
hashtag license plates is no longer no
longer in play and that the entire bill
has been
completely i'm looking at mr oberdink in
the back making sure he knows this
and the new amendment
entirely replaces the bill yes that is
correct um
it was my first time writing a bill and
i believe it was my ols person's also
first time writing a bill so it's not as
tidy as as
it ended up
so
these two amendments would
completely replace the first bill and um
the office
the financial office couldn't write me
an amendment but he was able to write
that this would fall under the 10 000 or
less category because
you know nobody wants to approve a 250
uh creation of a new plate so that is
off the table thanks thank you thank you
thank you for your question thank you
representative and
that those were the issues and i do
appreciate it we just have
we just have given a copy of that to mr
oberdenk too from dmv okay um so
hopefully it'll make things much easier
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
so i'm sorry miss knight klein klein
knight i'm sorry i hate to be a pain um
as a sub especially um is this a 501 c 3
organization
or is it for profit
right even though it says non-profit i
think it's neither because it's a state
agency
so that's why it's a little outside of
your usual uh purview i think is the
follow up
yeah i'm so sorry mr chair i have two
more questions has this has a state
agency done a decal
like um this before any state age in our
in our state um
oh is that for the chair or for
for anybody like you do
outside of the non-profits allow fire
department
and even with the amendment i would
still have to say we'll probably have to
do some more looking into this to make
sure that it's thorough enough to
include because that was going to bring
me to my next question
um
what it what it says it you should be
used to support nonprofit arts and
cultural programming what exactly does
that mean and where is that exactly
going to go
um that's not in the bill but that's the
amendment sorry
it's not in the amendment
it's on line 11. sorry no no i i have
grants are made with a combination of
state funds
allocated in the biennial budget process
federal funds from national endowment
for the arts in the past couple of years
the arts council has also made grants to
arts organizations with federal care act
and american rescue funds received from
the arts endowment and emergency grants
to individual artists through the
participation of the new england
foundation for the arts
some of the
uh
programs if that was your question that
they fund is
arts and health care
and
i know you know i've worked in some of
these programs and i don't know if
specifically they were funded you know
by the new hampshire council of the arts
but
easter seals
runs
arts and therapy groups
through the courier museum
and then there's a lot of outreach
programs that happen in the state
for
new citizens
i've just spent
a year
at the courier museum working
for the art for vets program
a program that
veterans can sign up for
and we do a combination of art looking
and art making
a wellness program um so there's a lot
of
the alzheimer's association also there's
a
alzheimer's memory cafe that
runs both at easter seals and at the
therapeutically people suffering from
alzheimer's and their caregivers in art
looking and aren't making kind of
activities so these are the kind of
mental health
and wellness programs that the state
council for the arts and others
also fund does that answer your question
representative just
last question i promise
um is it your intent that these proceeds
go to
uh funding
our mental health purposes specifically
or
or as the prime sponsor would you
be open to having them put wherever that
they decide yes i didn't want to specify
anything that would in any way
profit myself so i'm i'm hands off on
this what whatever the uh state council
for the arts chooses to grant
in their current grant um
applications that's up to them
thank you so much representative you're
welcome thank you for your question any
other further questions from the
committee
all right
um
and again we've got two issues here one
the policy and i don't think anybody is
opposed to that but even just reading
the amendment quickly looks like there
still may be some technical changes that
need to happen but we'll take care of
that if we can cross the first bridge
okay so i'm i'm available for any more
questions or
you know further on thank you so much
for hearing me today thank you very much
and i'll fill out the pink card and step
aside
thank you
jay recognizes uh jeff oberdenk from the
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
jeff
obernank and i'm here to provide
testimony on behalf of the division of
motor vehicles today and i must admit in
the last five minutes my testimony has
changed uh version 2.0 the bill looks a
lot better than version 1.0 getting rid
of hashtag alleviates a lot of stress
for us
and
the only thing that i would oppose going
forward mr chairman and respectfully i
think you mentioned it that it still
needs a little bit of work
to make sure that it fits into
the current regulation
having said that thank you for getting
rid of hashtag whoever did that
and and that'll conclude my testimony if
anybody has any questions
all right thank you sir we maybe reach
out to you any questions from the
committee
representative
thank you thank you very much mr
obernink um
do you
see any um
initial problems
with including a state agency
as like opening that door i think we're
all worried about opening the door to
another category
that's a great question uh
representative talarski i think that
door has already been opened by allowing
the fire service to do something
so i think this just opens it up a
little bit wider
thank you
any further questions
last call anybody else wish to speak to
house bill 1492.
seeing none i'll close the public
hearing
and what time do we have here
10 30.
for 10 24 right
you
okay we've got a few minutes to
to kill if you will i'm going to open up
the executive session on house bill 1001
fn
authorizing the girl scouts uh of the
green and white mountains to issue decal
plates for multi-use decal plates
is there a motion
representative
hospital telersky zero zero one dash fm
okay is there a second
hi
i'm not supposed to was that you
representative thompson
okay
sure
um
representative levick did a great job in
writing a very tight decal bill um that
would benefit the girl scouts
of the green and white mountains i think
we all know that the
girl scout organization does amazing
things for empowering girls and i would
love to give them this opportunity to
wear their pride their girl scout pride
on their stay plate
thank you for that any other discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role the motion isn't ought to pass
chair gagne yes
clerk votes yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg
yes
representative gorski yes
representative o'hare
yes
uh representative klein knight
uh representative rung is not here no
okay uh representative fenton yeah
representative rambo yes
representative rich
representative talersky yes
representative fox yes
uh stevens not here representative ayo
14-0
okay the committee recommendation about
to pass
it's approved 14-0
um is there any other motions are there
any emotions
consent's been moved without objection
consent it is
it's another close to the executive
we have time to do one more
just give us a moment for a reset thank
you
okay everybody welcome back
i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1060 fn
authorizing the new hampshire
environmental educators to issue decal
plates
i need a motion or on
60.
representative tillerson
thank you
i would like to make a motion of ought
to pass on house bill 1060 fn
motion about the pass is there a second
second by representative rich
oh
thank you sorry i wasn't expecting to
make the motion
um
i think we heard with representative
gagne's eloquent presentation of the
bill
that the new hampshire environmental
educators will do wonderful things with
the funds that they raise with this and
it'll help the students of hollis
see that their activism in action with a
jumping spider plate
fair enough thank you any other
discussion
i'll ask the clerk to call the role
on house bill 1060 the motion is opt to
pass
whenever she's ready
vice chairman gagne yes
clerk votes yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg
yes
representative gorski yes
representative o'hare yes
representative klein knight
yes
uh representative fenton yes
representative rompo yes representative
rich
representative talarsky
yes representative fox yes
representative value
yes and chairman walsh
yes
14-0
so the committee recommendation about to
pass on 1060 is adopted
i did hear a motion for consent any
objection to consent
seeing none consent it'll go
if anybody in hollis is watching
congratulations you get your details oh
sorry
do you want me to write that report so
she doesn't have to do both of those
sure
unless she really wants it doesn't
matter although i do have something to
point out that
to you or a question sure it was halfway
through the roll call
i checked the section both the girl
scouts and this bill are adding the same
exact line 13 or the 13th
or 18th
so
that's a great time to catch up sorry
um
you know what it does
i mean it's not the first time it's
happened exactly it happens with the
senate as well
uh we've already acted on it
unfortunately it may be an unenrolled
bill amendment to straighten out the
numbering yeah i just want to maybe we
could keep it in mind i'll verify that
if we have to reopen it with it with an
amendment we will but we'll reconsider
it we will but i think we'll be all
right going that route just wanted to
point out thank you thank you and
the report will be done by my colleague
over here thanks thank you for that sir
i'll close the executive session on
house bill 1060.
next hearing for 10 30 will be house
chair
if i may i just want to say how
impressed i am with the
in in in the
sharing of responsibilities in your
committee it is so nice and i love it
thank you so much for having me here
thank you welcome back and in
you
all right being 10 33 i'm gonna open up
the public hearing on house bill
1024 relative to local speed limits and
businesses or urban residence districts
uh if anybody wishes to sign in on the
bill before or against we have the blue
sheet out back
if you wish to speak to the bill i need
you to fill out a pink card and hand it
forward
we'll get to you uh chair recognizes
representative lang the prime sponsor
good morning good morning mr chair good
morning community members thank you for
taking my testimony today this is a
pretty simple one sentence bill making
changes to two characters in one
sentence
this bill is being brought at the
request of my selectmen i live in a late
community
what we're seeing around the state is in
our lakeside communities
urban density is starting to happen
we're having really tight small property
lands lots of houses
and in this case lots of houses
especially during the summer time means
lots of kids playing basketball in the
road doing other things
and we had a problem in our community
where again one of our our dense
population areas um the speed limit was
a problem for the citizens going through
there we're getting numerous complaints
from to the police about it
and what the selectmen when they did the
research found that the lowest they
could set in this urban area was a 25
mile an hour speed limit um which even
that was too fast for what was going on
so what this bill just does is allows in
certain in circumstances that's that's
selectmen deemed appropriate they can
lower the speed limit down to 10 miles
an hour and again i don't see selectmen
abusing this process it would still go
through the normal process of slowing of
speed limit posting which in our
community is is public hearings when
they're going to change a speed zone
they have a public hearing about it
and it would allow them to be able to
act in these hot more dense areas to be
able to lower the speed limit to a more
safe manner
so that we don't put
people at risk that's it pretty
straightforward thank you uh before we
open up the committee we have seen this
bill before
at least twice i believe um i believe in
current statute there is the ability for
a town or municipality to apply with the
commissioner of the department some
relief on the 25 do you know if your
select board has done that yet they were
aware of the process um again they
they were they were pursuing it but
again it was an
onerous process for lack of a better
phrase of having to to get the
permission and go to seek outside the
town someone else's permission to lower
the speed in your own town um and so
they felt that was onerous and and again
the selectmen asked me to bring forward
this bill because that the talent should
be able to set the speed limit within
its own confines without having to run
the department of transportation ask
permission
um
questions from the committee
representative
thank you mr chairman um so
just
hypothetically if my town was to adopt
this
could they set the main street to 10 but
still allow 25 in other urban business
areas
correct so this is a per street basis
like any other speed limit zone so you
have a maximum you know two lane divided
highways i think 45 miles is the maximum
speed limit allowed and so uh the
interstate's 70 right and so by statute
right so there are certain speed zone
zones that have prima facie speed limit
laws um
this the primary facial speed limit law
here is 25 which means that if they
don't post a sign then they can go up to
25 miles an hour i'm here if they post a
sign if there's no posted sign it's
assumed 10. um so
um
i'm not sure if that answered your
question but yes they can set a
differential you can have one section of
road at one speed another section road
with another speed up to 25 mile up to
whatever your normal is
because this is a not less than it's not
not a more than so
further questions
representative
uh thank you for taking my question i
think you just answered this so this
would
they're not they they cannot raise the
speed limit correct only lower it if
this were to pass correct this is a not
less than bill so in other words i can't
go less than 10 miles an hour but if 35
is appropriate i can set it at 35.
further questions from the committee
thank you thank you for taking my
question um it's quite a significant
jump in my mind picturing yourself in a
vehicle to go from 25 to 10. um is there
any logic to why they went so low is
15 even 15 occasionally you'll see 15 in
some parking lot or whatever
is there a reason why they went so
extremely low to 10
sure so the answer was again because
it's not a less than so they could
choose 15 if they wanted if this bill
was to pass they don't have to go to 10
but
they felt that again i think you'll see
this in a lot of lakefront communities
where you have really dense populations
right against the lake 10th of an acre
lots house after house after house and
in that area um a 10 mile an hour zone
may be appropriate
um and so uh that's the reason why the
selectman they i asked them what they
wanted they came back with this number
because of that dense population we only
have one small section of road to be
honest with you where this is really
going to apply um but where we have
really dense populations again house you
know
you can watch what your dinner you can
watch your neighbor's tv from your
window right the houses are right next
to each other and it's a really densely
populated area along the lake and
25 miles an hour which was the lowest
speed limit they could go to was too
much was was too fast
they wanted to slow it down i don't
think it's more than a tenth of a mile
to a half to a quarter of a mile um
stretch of road where it is so densely
populated that 25 is too much
further questions from the committee
rumbo
morning thank you for taking my question
uh i'm just curious if you had any input
from local law enforcement on if they
were concerned about
the dramatic drop changing um you know
coming in from
previous road or the beginning of the
road the quick drop off and kind of
extreme drop off and picking up again i
know in other communities when there's
been propositions for changing speed
limits there's been
sometimes concern about you know how how
i guess it would be either from
public works or police
sure so i did speak to our police chief
so i'm a former law enforcement officer
myself for over a decade
and and i did speak with our police
chief he was not concerned about this um
at all he felt again the the police the
police chief felt this was reasonable
for the conditions there um and that it
was an appropriate change
thank you further questions
representative klein knight
um thank you chairman thank you so much
representative for taking my question
um
there's no limit on the stretch of how
long this could go could this
potentially be any like how long is this
stretch that you're speaking about and
could this be
for any length so again a lot it could
be for any length so
so again if the town feels
uh that there's a stretch of road that's
a mile and a half long and they want to
they want to change the speed limit
again in most towns at least in our town
we have public hearings on those kind of
changes so people are made aware of it
they would have a public hearing on
we're going to change this this this
mile of road and the speed limits and
the police department be involved
department of transportation be involved
the highway department be involved and
come in and do it the problem here is
that you can't go below 25 miles an hour
right near stretches where they do want
to go below 25 miles an hour but can't
post and it wouldn't be legally
enforceable if they did post so and the
idea is to make it legally enforceable
so one of the other well i'll leave it
at that
thank you further questions from the
committee
follow-up um thank you so much and um i
i do like the intent um so i i apologize
i'm not trying to
put you through the ringer but um you
mentioned having town meetings on this
do you do they have to have a
a town meeting if this is
a state alteration law to speeding
or could the state without having a
meeting just
prove and enforce this
so to answer your question is that the
state law sets the minimums for the
community
and then the community implements from
the minimum up
so the community
so in this road that i'm particularly
talking about department of
transportation couldn't walk in without
the town's notice and say this is a town
road but the state's going to set a new
speed limit on it they can't do that
because it's a town maintained road town
regulated road and so um so to answer
your question i think is no um but it's
a it's a town activity um that isn't to
say there aren't state roads that run
through towns that you know you have
your your different route 140s 132s and
different
high state routes that run through towns
what are the questions representative
rambo it may be a follow-up to nicole's
actually but um
to make sure i understand then if this
were passed the town would still then
have to potentially have a hearing at
the town level
for residents to put input whether they
wanted to go down to 10 if it's at 25
right now but they were permitted to go
to 10 there would still have to be a
local
hearing is that correct correct there's
still local control local issues they
would still have to have a process in
place for lowering the speed limit it
just gives them the options in these
denser communities to be able to set a
lower speed limit to where they think
it's at risk for this citizens of that
area
further questions
next up chair recognizes and i apologize
if i'm mispronouncing this is it match
grace
just so it's on the record and h grades
for the new hampshire municipal
association we support this bill this is
a widespread problem that representative
lang has identified um it's not just the
the lakes region but we hear from select
boards across the state
uh about particular circumstances where
you know
there's a
densely um built up area where there are
lots of crosswalks and they're not good
sight lines or
you know uh elementary school or
something like that where the kids are
out close to the road and it's really is
appropriate it really is a safety issue
um they want to reduce the the speed
limit in those situations
unfortunately under the laws written
they can't reduce it lower than than 25
um so this would just modify it to 10
and we would certainly support that and
allow them and support the idea of
giving local communities the flexibility
to
adjust the speed limits as appropriate
for the particular circumstances that
they're facing
um in those cases
i'm happy to take questions all right
thank you
i won't bother asking the same question
twice uh
representative thompson
um
larger problem than than just uh
representative langstown who's going to
pay the bill
for the for the new speed limit signs
yeah
uh they would
pay them through the regular process um
this would modify that follow-up but it
would be the town
would be the town yeah okay on their
roads yes
thank you
for the questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
uh chair recognizes bill lambert from
the new hampshire department of
transportation
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee it's good to be back this
is a little bit different i haven't seen
this before
um i marked on the card posted the bill
recognizing that i hadn't heard
testimony so i wasn't sure exactly what
the background was
um essentially the the reason i oppose
the bill is because um
rsa 265 63 is specific to town
jurisdiction town and city jurisdiction
roads it's not
265 62 which is the state jurisdiction
and then the parent
basic law for speed limits is 265 60
which sets those statutory speed limits
so it doesn't necessarily affect state
speed zones uh however there's a number
of
state highways that are either
unnumbered routes or go through a
business district in a town that public
may not understand the difference so
that there is some parallel so i do have
some concerns
for the record bill lambert new
hampshire d.o.t
i've been the state traffic engineer for
21 years a lot of you folks know me
i've been
had the commissioner of transportation's
delegated responsibility for speed
limits since 2013 so the last eight
years i deal with speed limits a lot
i've been invited to speak at ite
national meetings on panel discussions
i've been participating in publications
on speed limits i'm currently working
with the new hampshire association
chiefs of police and i'll be meeting
with them next month at the meeting to
talk about how we set speed limits and
how we address the speed issue speed is
an issue
but but usually when people are
complaining about speed and they want
the speed limit load they're complaining
about people that are already 10 or 15
miles an hour over the posted speed
limit um so changing the number down is
not necessarily going to affect that
so some of the concerns i have with the
bill
is the one of its existing enforcement
and conviction issue i hear from police
all the time that if they go to a a
court with something less than 10 or 15
miles an hour
over the posted speed limit it'll get
tossed out that judges are unwilling to
even consider things that are five to
ten miles an hour over
and every time we arbitrarily lower
speed limits that are not credible for
the conditions that we change we we kind
of keep on that perception that the
speed limit is
10 or 50 miles an hour lower lower than
what's safe
10 miles an hour as stated earlier is
i'd say painfully slow if you've ever
tried to do 10 miles an hour it's not
possible
i talked about the overlap between the
local jurisdiction class five roads and
the state jurisdiction class two roads a
lot of which may not uh the public may
not know the difference so while this
applies to town jurisdiction roads uh i
could see people wanting to apply it to
both
and then speed limits should be
self-enforcing
the conditions of the road and the
character of the road and the
budding property development and
activity should be what drives us the
speed ideally the speed limit is based
on an engineering and traffic
investigation and it's set on a value
that most people will
will do because of the character of the
road not because of the sign
we tend to think especially in work
zones when we're continually pressed by
contractors and others the lower speed
limits we've been getting away from that
practice because we find changing the
value in the black and white sign
doesn't do a lot of good but if we put
up orange signs that tell people why
they should slow down and then put an
advisory speed panel for that value we
find that it's more effective because
you're telling people why they should
slow down so for conditions that were
described earlier our practice would be
to put up signs for either children
playing or whatever the condition is
winding road and then put an advisory
speed panel underneath that
there's a lot of discussion nationally
about changing the way we approach speed
limits and it's a lot of it's using
terms like safe systems approach and
they're talking about
looking at changing speed limits in
urban conditions so
i'm aware of that i'm participating a
lot of panel discussions about that and
been a lot involved with regional and
national discussions on on how that
changes the problem that i have is that
changing the number on the sign without
changing the character of the road is
not changing the speed of traffic one of
the things i deal with a lot
is trying to get people to understand
that
the speed limit is a maximum value and
we keep trying to drop these speed
limits down so it's perceived as a
minimum value that people are going at
least the speed limit this morning on my
way to work on manchester street for
those that might not know on manchester
street route 3 going towards pembroke
from concord two lanes that then go
through the signals into pembroke i'm in
the left lane because i'm gonna make a
left to get to my office doing 45 and i
think it's posted 50 but i'm climbing
the hill at a steady rate and with snow
on the ground and the person that passed
me on the right stuck his hand out the
window with a one finger salute
we've got this perception that people
think if you're driving responsibly that
people think you're going too slow and
changing the number and the signs not
changing that perception we need to do a
lot more
outreach to get people to change their
behavior and with that i'd be happy to
take any questions all right thank you
sir i i do have one before i open up to
the committee is there anything in
statute that would prevent
municipalities in these urban areas or
high density areas from doing
other things like speed calming measures
such as speed bumps
no certainly on um
on the town jurisdiction roads things
like chicanes speed humps
narrowing roads on street traffic all of
that kind of friction tends to slow
traffic down a whole lot better than
the value of the number on a black and
white sign thank you questions from the
committee
representative tallerski thank you thank
you for taking my question i just wanted
to clarify when you talk about
the overlay of state roads and town
roads so your implication
is that there are some state roads that
go through these towns
that maybe the speed limit does drop but
because it's a state road the town does
not have any control
to lower the speed limit on that section
of road is that correct yeah i mean the
the commissioner of transportation has
authority on all the state roads so all
the numbered routes theoretically uh
except for the urban compacts and but
there's a lot of
what we call tier five roads the
unnumbered state routes that uh that are
state maintained and the commissioner of
transportation has jurisdiction for and
unless you're familiar with the process
and know which one is a state versus
town
the public's not going to know that and
somebody mentioned belmont earlier so
140 in belmont
takes a hard left at main street if
you're on 140 that's a state route but
if you take the right on the main street
which looks like the main route that's a
town road
and that goes more or less through the
business district of belmont most of the
public's not going to be aware of that
they don't necessarily just see the
difference
thank you for the questions
representative
thank you for taking my question you
might have answered this is there a 10
mile an hour speed limit anywhere in new
hampshire uh thank you for the question
i believe the only place in statute that
allows a 10 mile an hour speed limit is
in alleys
and i want to say 20 something years ago
manchester um changed the speed limit or
introduced that value because there's
places between buildings where cars are
allowed to travel
at 10 miles an hour but other that than
that on a public road class 5
there's probably places that are
advisory speeds of 15 miles an hour and
further questions
i have one more just out of curiosity
how many requests
a year does the department get
to drop below the 25 below 25. thank you
the only one that i can think of and it
wasn't on a state jurisdiction road
was when portsmouth has
locations that are in market square that
are 20 i think those are not compliant
with the current statute and i think
they tried to change this bill a couple
years ago
so i don't get a lot of requests for
going below 20.
we get the occasional to go to 25.
we changed the interpretation of rsa 265
62 a few years ago
it used to say or it does stay that the
commissioner can consider
as low as 25 in compact parts of cities
and towns the d.o.t had always
interpreted that to mean that formal
urban compact so like the city of
concord
downtown franklin places like that that
have formal urban compacts
when we several years ago the town of
tilton wanted to lower the speed limit
in downtown tilton which is not an urban
compact and we took a look at the
statute and we reinterpreted compact
parts of cities and towns to be a
density definition and not an urban
tilton
new market um
there's one other town that escapes me
to go to 25 miles an hour all right
thank you
representative telersky thank you very
quickly thank you for taking my question
um we discussed briefly the process of a
town um
applying
for a waiver on this can you just tell
us quickly what that would entail and
what the time frame
thank you for the question um i heard
the question and the discussion about a
waiver process
i'm not aware of that that might be
something i'd have to review with the
ag's office
i know that rsa 265 63
allows the taos the towns to
change speed limits within their
jurisdiction but it it's also subject to
an engineering and traffic
engineering investigation
traffic investigation is not defined in
statute but in practice and in
the dot practice it involves a fairly
comprehensive
includes a speed study evaluation of
geometry
uh crash history and um
things like that and typically per the
federal manual on uniform traffic
control devices the speed limit should
be set within five mil five miles an
hour of a measured 85th percentile speed
so a lot of people have asked me in the
past to drop the speed limit so they can
drop the speed
don't understand that the
concept
in practice is to
determine what people are naturally
doing because of the character of the
road and setting the speed limit based
on what most people feel is reasonable
and prudent for conditions
so i think the answer to your question
is that towns and cities would have to
follow that same process of doing an
engineering and traffic investigation
if it is a
within an urban area that's a state
jurisdiction road
they have the ability to petition the
the commission of transportation
to consider going as low as 25 and we've
done that like i said in new market in
tilton and
one out of the town at least that that
escapes me at this time
we've also in
something else that you may be aware of
in this group some of you may be aware
of that senator stiles filed a bill
several years not that many years ago to
allow towns and cities even on state
roads to to adopt a seasonal speed limit
so they can go as low as i think 10
miles an hour less than the normal speed
limit
in uh for up to four months a year in
places that are seasonally congested by
bicycles and pedestrians
and the process for that is if they
petition the department we have
somewhat a of a review to make sure that
we can confirm that um that the place is
likely to be congested with bikes and
peds during that time frame
but it's essentially it's a rubber stamp
if the town is interested in doing the
sign work um
for our approval then they can lower the
speed limit up to 10 miles an hour on
during
questions and actually just jog my
memory too and now i remember this the
seasonal further questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
uh this last person i have signed up to
speak uh last call for anybody that
wishes to
seeing none i'll close the public
hearing on house bill 1024
uh 11 o'clock 11 38
being 11 o'clock i'm going to open up
the public hearing on house bill 1138
fna
um
exempting the display of a front license
anybody wishes to sign in on the bill
for against we do have the blue sheets
out back anybody wishes to speak and
fill out a pink card and hand it forward
please
chair recognizes the prime spots or
good morning
good morning thank you mr chairman
i am andrew proud representing
hillsborough county district 37 the
towns of hudson and pelham
this bill will create an exemption
process for the requirement for a
vehicle to display a front license plate
upon presentation of evidence that it
would alter its historic character its
collectibility or devalue the vehicle
the mounting of a front license plate
can have significant effect effect on
the value of certain vehicles
this is especially true with collectible
cars higher-end sports cars and importer
imported vehicles that may not have been
designed for a north american-shaped
license plate
this bill would require exempted
vehicles to display a decal sticker on
the windshield so that the exemption
could be known to law enforcement
similar to the requirement for custom
cars in rsa
[Music]
on the 89-d
which are already exempt from displaying
vehicles with rear-only license plates
are already on our roads
20 states and 9 out of 13 canadian
providences
do not require front license plates
seven additional states have exemptions
for certain vehicle types or categories
ohio recently repealed its front plate
requirement on passenger vehicles
effective in 2019
and new hampshire permits cities and
towns to issue commemorative license
plates which may be displayed in lieu of
a front license plate during an
anniversary year
making it clear that it's not critical
for all vehicles to display a front
number plate
thank you for your time and
consideration i'd be happy to answer any
questions the committee may have
thank you representative any questions
representative rambo
morning thank you did i hear you explain
that there is already um exemption for
custom vehicles in certain circumstances
and i apologize the committee if i need
to be educated on this
thank you for the question on the front
plate sorry to be clear yeah thank you
for the question the one i mentioned was
for custom vehicles but i am also aware
there's also an exemption for hot uh
registered i think it's either hot rods
or street rods i don't know the exact
term but those two vehicle categories
both have explicit uh exemptions in the
rsas to not have to display a front
light number
plate
representative gorski
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative take my question
is this sticker like something that's
renewable each year or is it like a
one-time kind of thing
uh
at least as written in the bill it would
be a one-time thing although i believe
there was i added a provision that if
you've got a windshield replacement you
can buy a new one okay thank you
further questions from the committee
representative fenton
uh thank you for the question and thank
you for being here today
um i don't see anything about
uh
if i don't have the sticker
thank you for the question uh
you're right i would there's nothing
explicitly stating what the
repercussions are but i would
at least with the way it's worded you
wouldn't be meeting the terms of your
exemption because it says that you shall
display it as part of the exemption and
waiver process so that point i would
think that you would not be meaning the
terms of the exemption and you could
still be cited for not properly
displaying a front plate
follow-up so
wouldn't we need a new
[Music]
uh penalty for this so i apply for this
i don't have the front plate i don't
have the sticker on what am i being
excited for and what's the
penalty for that
thank you for the question i
would think that we wouldn't need a new
penalty you just apply the existing
penalty for not displaying a new front
plate because
if you haven't met the terms of your
exemption and the exemption then
you aren't exempt from the existing fine
thank you
for the questions representative run
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
i'm a little bit curious about what
on line six where you mentioned that uh
the the number plate reduces the
historic character its collectibility um
and the devaluation or the value of the
vehicle
um
i and i've bought a lot of cars over the
years and i don't know if the having a
front license plates impacted the the
market value of that do you know why
that's included in the bill
thank you for the question um
there's
certainly
many types of collectible cars
especially
cars that at least are notable and older
might depend exactly on the age where
people take great value
having them in their original condition
as they were made and often that's
without a front plate mounting bracket
um i can especially can think of people
that like to take cars around to car
shows
they don't want to alter the vehicle
from its original character to add that
and if they did
then it would lower its resale value
especially in the 20 other states that
further questions from the committee
representative thompson
do you have any idea how many people are
going to want to do this
um
is this been a big thing because it
seems like state's going to invest a lot
of time and energy and money
into
only only be required by
a few hundred people
thank you for the question uh i
certainly have not done a um
attempted to create a precise count of
how many people want this i have had
many people contact me um
and say they're contacting mbi for
organizations that have more members
that also are interested um
specifically
the i think it's a porsche motor club
that are definitely very interested in
applying for this what that will add up
to i couldn't tell you at this point
yeah it is
it is indeterminable according to the
fiscal note but i will tell our guests
on transportation that
exemptions from the front plate um
have been heard quite quite often in the
past few years in transportation
any further questions from the committee
representative tallerski
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
i understand
the discussion as we've heard many times
about
collectible cars historic cars that type
of thing and the attempt of this
committee last year to pass something
similar for
antiques and hot rods which i believe
was killed in the senate transportation
committee
but
the ambiguity of line six representative
that
if you believe it's going to devalue
your vehicle well
anyone could probably
or would you agree with me
that the way this is written
anyone could say this is going to
devalue my vehicle and it could be
someone who spends seventy thousand
dollars on a porsche or a tesla or even
someone who spends a lot of their hard
earned money on a brand new honda crv
um i guess i'm just
trying to understand
where this would be limited
uh thank you for the question uh you are
correct that i didn't want to get
too deep into the specifics in
uh line six but that's also a little bit
why i have in line seven that they have
to include a statement from
somebody that knows these things either
car dealer appraiser or collector
and good information to support the
waiver um i wouldn't think that it would
be considered very well supported if the
estimated devaluation was ten dollars or
something like that
um
as far as if you wanted if the committee
wanted to tighten up that language and
try to make more specific about how much
devaluation would have to happen to
qualify that's certainly not something i
would be opposed to but it is i thought
a little bit challenging for exactly
it could be subjective any further
questions from the committee
um i've got representative klein knight
i will try to go around again um thank
you so much chair and i know you're
looking at me and i have like six
questions so if the other representative
wants to take i i am if if you want me
to go last i certainly will well you're
assuming i'm going to give you something
yeah i hope that i really hope you do
but i recognize you first i want you to
start with one of them okay
are you aware that most vehicle
manufacturers offer a front license
plate mounting bracket designed for your
model of vehicle that attaches to the
underside of the bumper and might not
even require drilling holes and devalue
your vehicle at all
thank you for the question i
am aware that most new
vehicle manufacturers do that
i wouldn't say all necessarily
especially in regards to imported cars
that might be designed for european
style license plates
of course one of the issues of this
build is the older cars that that might
not be true for
um
follow-up
for this one particular
um could you give us a list of those
specific vehicles that um won't be able
to
adopt a
hanging license plate
how how many vehicles this would affect
in the state
uh
thank you for the question i
can't give you a
list of models or is or certainly not at
this time a count of vehicles in the
state
um
and
i think
cant is a strong word i think we have
seen for vehicles registered in the
state that people have gotten even when
the manufacturer doesn't provide an
option creative and how to make it
happen
but in many cases
either directly or indirectly because
it's
loose and flopping around that may have
devalued the vehicle some
thank you representative thompson
um it seems to me like
the problem here is going to be that the
first line of defense
in registering your car is a town clerk
so who's going to get to decide whether
you get a waiver or not is the town
clerk going to be presented with that
waiver
and is it their decision or does it have
to go to motor vehicle
before she can register your car i'll
answer that one for you just as a matter
of time
um all the bill says is that you display
the front plate so everybody will still
be issued the two so they'll still get
the two yeah okay plus the sticker
well well that's true we do have the
decal on this bill yeah
he does have a point with the decal
thank you for the question um
i'm
trying to find the line number as i
answer this question but the
waiver request would go to the state dmv
is was the intent and i'm if he can give
me a minute i'll probably find where but
that was the intent is the decal would
come from the state and the waiver
request would go to the state the
process for applying for the waiver was
modeled after the process for applying
for a medical exemption from equipment
which is most often used for a window
tint but can be also
that section of rsa can also be used for
other medical exemptions as well
fair enough don't bother i don't believe
at this point
still fair to say i was accurate saying
you're still going to get issued two
plates
at the time of registration there would
be nothing thank you for the question
there'd be nothing in this bill that
would change that correct thank you
the sticker would only allow the
exemption to not put one on the front
further questions from the committee and
i asked for time sake
these are a lot of
questions on statistics and things these
are things that we can look into before
we execute which will not be today so
any other questions from the committee
representative clinton i'm sorry this is
a really good one you're gonna love it
um
when you say display you don't define
that does that mean somebody can just
put this
in their front mirror and it doesn't
have to be visible
and
if
that's true would you be amenable to an
amendment to define the actual word
i'll take the question we can look into
that it is a good point it may be very
well covered
and can i keep asking questions
okay
i'll give you one more
um have you thank you fair enough have
you worked with the dmv at all to know
how much the cost is going to be to the
thank you for the question
i believe that is fairly well covered in
the fiscal note of the bill
um
the i would
i would want to work with the state more
to find out whether their initial
purchase number is appropriate and that
goes i think to some of your some of the
questions earlier about do we know how
many people will be wanting to apply for
this
you know which goes to how much initial
stock they would have to buy
but the fiscal note does cover
the topic of buying the initial stock of
the decal stickers
in terms of those questions we do have
other people that are signed up that may
be able to answer them thank you so much
uh any further questions for the
representative
our chair recognizes
it looks like john drury
uh chief of police association opposed
should see a red light thank you good
morning uh
uh chairman and members of the committee
um i do have some uh documentation here
as well i i won't bore you with it um
you saw me last year um
on the same testimony i have tweaked it
a little bit
but these copies are are obviously
we i can pass them out as well
my name is john drury and i'm the chief
of police of farmington new hampshire
i've just started my 23rd year in law
enforcement i am here to testify in
opposition to bill hb 1138 fn relative
to number plates for motor vehicles on
behalf of myself and new hampshire
chiefs of police association
thank you for allowing me to address
this bill as a car guy
i dislike the front plate
as a police officer and a member of the
regional accident reconstruction team i
must admit i love them
over the years the front plate has made
my job much easier route 11 75 and 153
are main state roads that run through
farmington when a neighboring police
department issues a bolo
be on the lookout for
we head out onto the roads and try to
find that car if we were to be looking
for a red toyota prius with only rear
plates on it it would be difficult to
find as we would have to position
ourselves in a location
to try and observe these as most rear
plates are recessed under the trunk lid
or a hatch or a space uh in the rear
bumper
or we just spin around and try to get
behind the car to read the plate imagine
trying to do this during rush hour with
a long line of traffic all going 50
miles per hour or more
watching a car pass you and then seeing
the plate get smaller and smaller
the state now issues a seven digit plate
and this can be very challenging
new hampshire plates are reflective and
stand out very well they're easy to read
day or night many times during a
collision the front plate gets left
behind at the scene or gets missed or it
gets imprinted into other vehicles like
a stamp we've saw many hit and runs this
way when we could read this or find the
plate this can also happen in load speed
crashes i personally witnessed one at
about 15 miles an hour it was
unbelievable i was standing right there
the car slid into another vehicle and
that plate imprinted on the bumper of
the other car
perfectly
a car that is involved in a robbery
often pulls into a business and with
that video equipment we can read the
plate and get a good description of the
car
banks do a great job of capturing the
front plate and the driver but not so
much the rear of the car
if a vehicle has a trailer on it forget
it about getting that rear plate
information and especially at the tolls
this would cost the state a lot of money
at lost toll revenue
aerodynamically i spoke to a mechanical
engineer on our tar team
wind drag
is a function of square feet of surface
area and it won't bore you with it but
when you have a very small license plate
followed by a huge bumper and a radiator
and all of the equipment behind that
pushing that
small license plate through the air that
is a negligible
amount of aerodynamics and we even
discussed that 5 psi
loss in tire pressure would be far more
than pushing that small front plate
putting a decal on a vehicle um instead
of a front plate in my opinion will not
work as we will not see it at night can
you imagine having only one plate on
your car and yes you have the decal but
you keep getting pulled over by law
enforcement because we can't
we can't see it at night we're all
we're just focused you know i'm looking
for that front plate and trying to
discover
you know the plate and sometimes you
just memorize the last four of a bolo
vehicle so
the first three may not be quite so
important so you're looking at the last
four of the plate trying to determine
that vehicle and then going okay this
matches the car i'm looking for and then
verifying the whole license plate
um now
now as uh
the representatives said or i apologize
one of your questions was after market
products um there are some
uh they attach if you look on your car
you see a small little um
square on the front bumper of your car
that's where the tow hooks so if you
were to need a tow
they popped that off attached to your
tow hooks on the front of your car and
they've been ingenious in making those
so now your front bla you have a after
market bracket that can fit into that
and not damage your bumper and that was
something different from from last
so i just wanted to hope
in closing i must oppose this bill for
the safety of the public it outweighs my
car guy vanity i do like cars
and trust me it
it does pain me with a front plate but
the benefits so much outweigh um that
that little problem that i have with the
front plate uh and it has just helped us
in my career
countless times of having that front
plate there making it our job a lot
easier i thank you very much for
allowing me the opportunity to testify
uh on this on behalf of this bill
and uh in opposing it and i would
respectfully ask
that you find it in
expedient to legislate and thank you so
much for your time
i'd be more than happy to take any
questions if you have any yep thank you
just one question for me does the
federal government state law or the
manufacturers
illuminate the front plates at night
that that is not a requirement only the
rear plate has a plate light so the
front plate is not required to be
illuminated and like i say our plates
with the
the green and white they stand out so
well
thank you it just isn't needed
sorry about that thank you for taking my
question you said that seeing a sticker
would be hard at night but how would you
how do you see inspection stickers since
they're just little stickers in the
bottom corner windows at night
well i wish we were consulted in
the inspection sticker process but to
the best of my knowledge we weren't um i
i will say i just like our current
inspection stickers and i'm sure uh it
costs the state some revenue because
they're also hard to see
and i would agree with you that that
decal is is going to make our job more
difficult
the inspection stickers have been
improved since that
first go-around a couple of years ago
but i think there's still some more room
follow-up
is this something you'd be willing to
work with us on trying to find a way
around
[Music]
let's find a way to get rid of the front
plate
because it's always coming up so is that
something you're willing to work on or
is it something that we just can't right
now
i i think it would be very difficult i'm
always willing to work with anybody on
anything to solve any problem
but i just
the front plate is just such a benefit
to us i i just think uh i think we have
to keep things the way they are thank
you though for the question all right
um we do have other people
from departments signed up to speak
in speaker
excuse me chief could if you have
written testimony could i get a copy of
that most definitely i apologize i'd be
more than happy to pass it out i have
several copies here and would be uh
would be an honor to share them with you
thank you any further questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you thank you very
much
chair recognizes lieutenant james
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee
my name is lieutenant james o'leary from
the hampshire state police troop g
and the chiefs of police association
just took away everything that i have to
say
so i know that you have other people to
speak the only part that i will share
with you is this
i've worked a number of years in
collision analysis reconstruction and
can attest to the fact that there are
license plates that do get left at
scenes
because of those those rear collisions
in addition to that i worked a number of
years as a homicide investigator and we
rely heavily on surveillance video cell
phone video and eyewitness testimony
when it comes to identifying vehicles
involved in crimes and obviously having
that front license plate is very
advantageous for us for that so
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative palerski thank you i'll
be very quick um the only thing that
hasn't come up that i know we've heard
in the past and i just want to verify
i'm correct in my memory um amber alerts
i know that when an amber alert is
issued your point is to reach out to the
general public and i know the general
public isn't always necessarily behind a
vehicle as a cruiser might be
do you think the front plate is vital
for the public to identify amber alert
yes ma'am thank you for your question
that's exactly what happens in an amber
alert that gets messaged out to the
public and we rely solely on the public
to attempt to locate that vehicle so if
that front plate is there it does make
it easier for the public to find that
vehicle for us thank you
further questions
representative crawford
thank you mr chair thank you lieutenant
license plate readers we allow those in
the state of new hampshire
as of right now i believe we're working
on language regarding that but we do not
have any that that are uh
so if we if if departments do have them
would they be reading just the front
license plate or do they read both
i apologize i don't know the answer to
that question as far as how that
technology works if they read both
plates thank you okay
further questions from the committee
jay recognizes the final speaker on this
bill that signed up at this point um
jeff oberdenk from the department of
motor vehicles
good morning again mr chairman of
members of the committee i'll make my
um
my part brief as well and i look at this
from a different perspective i look at
this from the guy who's got to manage
this program
um and whenever we see programs that
come through like this waiver programs
we want to run from the room for this
for the for the ambiguity that that's in
the in the language here and
this is an unenforceable act
for us because of the am
the ambiguous language
what's to prevent me from denying the
owner of a 2012 subaru forester from
saying that it's not a collectible
so if i deny somebody that sticker there
is a hearings there's an administrative
hearings process
in which every citizen has the right
when denied a product what is my
defensible point from this this program
so basically what i'm saying is this is
an undefensible program for anybody that
wants to apply
because collectible is in the eye of the
beholder
value is in the eye of the beholder
there is no
set
program rules or regulations in play
that defines what is collectible
and having said that i'll keep it at
that and i'll open it up to any
questions
thank you sir questions from the
committee representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman um and thank you
for taking my question would you be open
to working with us on
defining
what is uh collectible what is you know
the devaluing so we can get to a point
where we know which type of vehicles
they're targeting
for not having front plates and
it's the more the ferrari stuff like
that
not the subaru foresters and we know
that so were you are you able to work
with us on maybe defining these words
and getting something that could
pass for this sure if there's if there's
language that exists that would get us
closer to a definition of a program that
we could actually
adhere to i think we all think a model t
or a ferrari is what we're talking about
here but the language doesn't say that
fair enough representative fenton
uh thank you for taking my question
hypothetically let's say i own a car
dealership
could i charge people for this waiver
and approve any car
uh not according to this waiver it is it
appears to be a department program in
the 15 fee shall cover the cost of the
sticker
um
representative palersky
thank you thank you for taking my
question um i
pulled up the notes on house bill 260 fn
from last year which um
was amended by this committee to have a
rear plate only for collectibles hot
rods and i think antique vehicles and
the
senate
giving it an itl recommendation and it
failed the senate
primarily because of toll problems
collect collections of tolls can you
expand a little bit on that and the
possible fiscal impact um
of cars that don't have a front plate
for reading by the tolls
i don't know if that's your purview
i think that's a that's a department of
transportation say i will say that we
are the end point once again
for the department of transportation
when it comes to suspending
um folks who haven't paid their tolls so
whether this adds significantly or not i
don't think i could attest to okay thank
you
with no other questions thank you very
much
um
one more speakers come forward
representative cody belanger
good afternoon mr chair members of the
committee i'm actually here today
and good morning good morning
so many of you know um my name is cody
belanger and i represent the center of
the universe that's epping new hampshire
in case anybody didn't know
uh this bill for me is personal
some of you know i own a car service
recently i just bought a brand new
lincoln continental i drove out to
missouri to buy this beautiful car it's
black
if i
if
currently right now and
i'm not comfortable doing this but i
have to by law
drill two holes in the front of that
bumper
because it didn't come with a front
license plate
mount
this bill
would allow me to
wave that
now keep in mind motorcycles don't have
this issue
we don't have front plates on
motorcycles we have back plates
so if the issue is with tolls i'm pretty
sure the toll
camera grabs the um
the the back of the plate anyway
um
so
if that's not the problem then how are
we if if that is a problem then how are
we not billing for
motorcycles that don't get captured when
they go through the toll and they don't
have their easy pass
this bill
really
is as simple as it gets
i have a fifty thousand dollar car that
i have to drill two holes into the front
of
it kills me that i have to do this
i want to cry
any questions for the representative
cnn thank you very much thank you mr
chair members that's me
uh that's the last person i have signed
up to speak is there anybody else here
that wishes to speak on house bill 1138
seeing then i'll close the public
hearing
and
let me go
over there
just give me a minute to reset and we'll
being 11 35 i'm going to open up the
public hearing on house bill 1150
representative ankerberg if you're going
to introduce this right
if you can fill out a pink card while
i don't like this one at all
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
i'm here to introduce house bill 1150
and this is uh relative to temporary
license plates
and this bill would permit
any new hampshire resident who purchases
a motor vehicle from another individual
to display an existing valve new
hampshire license plate registered in
their name for a period of five days
from the date of sale
so the intent of this is
clearly you're on craigslist facebook
marketplace something like that
um it's late on a saturday
you you talk to the seller you like the
car um you know most most of these
situations you're not
in a position where you know the person
they're not going to hold the vehicle
you kind of have to act on it at that
point
um obviously dmv and your town clerk
aren't open
so how do you get a temp tag
right
difficult so this bill is uh seeking to
remedy that particular issue
um
just uh i i would see a couple of issues
with the bill as it's as it's written
maybe we can fix some of these maybe the
committee can fix these
there is an issue
on line four any resident of this state
who purchases a motor vehicle in another
state from another person i would think
that it might be
sort of a problem if police in another
out-of-state jurisdiction um
notice that you're driving around on a
you know in a vehicle with a plate
registered to another car
um it could be a problem you're probably
gonna get pulled out of that car
further investigation
also
there's nothing in the bill
requiring
a bill of sale
and how that would be
authenticated
to prevent folks from simply at the end
of the five-day period simply writing a
new bill of sale
um and just going on and on with that
process
there would be no way to authenticate
that
you know bill of sale would be um valid
so
with with that said i i like the idea
and hopefully the committee can work on
it
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative
thank you mr chairman i don't know if
this is more of a question for the chair
i think it'd probably be more towards
for aiden i'm sorry representative
um
is if you were to get pulled up right
now after buying a car on sunday and you
had a bill of sale in your car and your
old plates in the car
what's the likelihood of that cop giving
you that ticket
for that if it if that bill of sale says
that day i can't answer that that'd be a
question for
the department of safety perhaps one of
our other speakers can maybe answer that
one for you thank you any other
questions from the committee
representative gorski thank you mr
chairman and take representative for
taking my question so let me make sure i
get i understand this
if
i go to another state go to
massachusetts and i see this car and i
want to purchase it from this person
it's a saturday evening
and i'd say this is a second car for me
are you saying i could take my plates
off my current car
kind of bring them with me
light the car and then slap him on this
car
and then drive home is that kind of the
the bill says that
uh obviously there would be some issues
with that right
you know depending on um
the law in the other state right so if
we were to pass this and you're in
another state driving an unregistered
vehicle out of massachusetts let's say
you know that that would present a
problem okay thank you
further questions from the committee
seeing none you're off the hook thank
you
um chair recognizes lieutenant james
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
thank you representative for giving my
testimony
so
essentially all the points that the
representative brought up were ones that
were going to bring up as well um you
know that i understand the intent behind
the request however our biggest concern
would be that we would have no way to
authenticate any of the paperwork that
the driver may have that's not required
yet as the bill is written or able to
run the license plate that's attached to
the to the vehicle and have it come back
to the proper vehicle so that those are
our major concerns for us of course so
could you answer my same question i'm
sorry i didn't hear what your question
was
if you were to pull someone over and the
it's a they give you a bill of sale and
they're running their plate that they
just took off their other car and
they're going home what's the likelihood
you're actually giving them a ticket if
that's the only issue they're going home
wow okay um there's probably a pretty
good likelihood of that honestly because
attaching that plate um you know from
that from their vehicle to another car
in and of itself is a is a law violation
um so now you've got the car that's not
registered at all plus they've already
swapped over the plate so there's kind
of a couple of things going on there so
that is a concern again only because we
have no way of validating any of the
information that's that's transferred
thank you for the question i guess you
brought up another issue if i'm
purchasing this vehicle and say it's an
antique and it's not inspected
i would get pulled over for
the car being not inspected as well
correct if there's no sticker on it
correct there is a potential that it
would get pulled over for not being
inspected because it would have hard you
know registration plates on it without
get used to these things one of these
days
chair recognizes jeff overdank from the
department of motor vehicles
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee uh once again the dmv
also opposes this bill for a number of
reasons that have been outlined but i
think most importantly for us when you
receive one of our registrations in one
of our plates that there is an
expectation that you're going to be
successful no matter where you go
and this bill certainly undermines that
if you're purchasing a vehicle out of
state who may not be familiar with our
state laws
so purchasing that vehicle somewhere
else and throwing a different plate on
it for lack of a better term and driving
away as lieutenant o'leary just spoke of
chances are you're not proceeding
if you're out of state and they can't
determine if that car belongs on that
plate
somebody roadside may think seamlessly
well this is because of a car sale and i
think if you're in new hampshire you can
determine that if it's a new hampshire
law but if you're roadside in another
state three or four states away
purchasing a vehicle they have no idea
if you've stolen those plates from
somebody else or taking them off another
vehicle fraudulently
chances are that vehicle is not going to
make it back with you to new hampshire
in a timely fashion and it also does
talk about the inspection program the
only way that you get
a 20-day plate on a vehicle is if it's
inspectable or in is is inspected or if
it's in inspectable condition
and you're kind of throwing that to the
side if you're saying throw a good plate
on a car that hasn't been inspected or
that you don't know is in inspectable
condition
with that i'll take any questions you
may have thank you
questions from the committee
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question um it seems there are some
deficiencies in the bill but
is there anything here that would
prevent someone from
taking their plate off of their car at
home driving it for the five days and
then
just keep it on
and keep going there's no
there's no
clear penalty with the penalty if caught
then fall under the driving uh
unregistered car or misuse of plates
sure if you have good driving habits
chances are nobody's going to know yeah
right and then and again there there
goes that revenue that again the point
of the registration is putting that
money back into the infrastructure in
which you're traveling on and if you're
doing it for 20 30 100 days
you're not paying that registration fee
that belongs to the road use for that
car
thank you
representative gorski
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
if i
let's say i go down to massachusetts to
buy a vehicle from somebody can you
explain kind of the
the process
that i should be going through
in order to
you know get that registered before i
drive away with that vehicle from a
person
well i certainly i can't answer what
other states would do and whether or not
they're going to give you a temporary
tag to get the vehicle home i know that
most do
actually we have somebody from nhada
that may be able to answer that question
uh but having said that
we would issue a 20-day plate to any
vehicle that's road-worthy and allow
them to continue on their way
and
one would assume that if you're if
you're buying a vehicle at a dealership
that you'd be doing the same and getting
the same treatment
follow-up yep follow-up if if i'm buying
it from a person sure
do i do i have to like go and get
temporary plates before
i'm able to drive away with that is that
kind of the process absolutely
everything's got to be registered before
it goes on the road okay thank you
further questions representative fenton
um i sympathize with this because i have
purchased cars off craigslist and it can
be kind of cumbersome running to the dmv
and getting a red plate and all that
would you be open to a program where
maybe you apply an advance with a vin
number in the car and show that it's
inspected and you could go down there
and put a temporary plate on it you
issue a template assigned to that car
would that be some sort of program
that's
possible yeah we'd be interested in
hearing the the thought process on that
and
and what could work because we certainly
have a 20-day plate program
that works very well and as you know
works very well monday through friday
it's just those off-hour purchases right
fair enough any other questions from the
committee
seeing then thank you very much
that's the last person i have signed to
speak on
house bill 1150 is there anybody else
that wishes to
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing
our next public hearing uh one o'clock
house bill 1158
you
okay we'll introduce house bill 1158
ah there you are representative dennis
green
good afternoon mr chair good afternoon
honorable committee
my name is dennis green i represent
hampstead kingston which is rockingham
13.
and
i believe that is all
in my bill here 1158 relative to use the
the reason i brought this forth is i had
a friend of mine that always left his on
the mirror
and one day he was crossing a side road
on 111
and
he got broadsided
a vehicle on 111 was going west and he
didn't see it
the other time was
i was up at cmc
and i was looking for a handicap spot
because i had to go into the hospital
and i couldn't find one so i had to park
down the street
and
as i was coming into the hospital
there's a
hospital police officer
and i asked him if he'd mind checking
the plaques on the cars that were there
and he did and he got back to me and he
says yeah there was one that was expired
and
i have a friend i had a friend he passed
away also
that
was riding around with the
expired card
and when i had my
gas
not gas station but repair shop i
wouldn't do a sticker if a person came
in and left it on the mirror because it
says right on the cards right at the top
please remove before driving
and i see so many vehicles riding around
them left on the windshield
and
if you've taken a few moments and gone
to some places like walmart lowe's or
home depot
you'll see people coming in and park
their car and get out and you'll say
why have they got a card they're walking
with no problems whatsoever
and they're young
so i don't know i didn't go
question them but
this just seems like there's an abuse to
these cards if you don't want to remove
it from the windshield then get the
handicapped plate
any questions for this
go ahead representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question you're welcome
i guess i'm a little confused as
um
to the intent or the change you're
trying to make here
um
your story about a friend getting hit
broadside yes um i don't understand what
the placard had to do with that
he didn't see the car why blocking his
vision
the hanging card was blocking his vision
okay thank sorry i'm sorry mr chairman
may i just sure
i'm looking for the intent of this
so
you're adding in verbage that says
a removable windshield placard
shall not be displayed
okay so your intent is that they remove
it while driving it's the law it is the
law so i guess i'm wondering
why you're needing to put it in here
well i'd feel it as being totally abused
and
and the other thing is
i didn't read to the point that i wish i
had time to go down to
legislative help there and change it
on a third offense
for 90 days
i would rather see them do a 10 mile
follow it please sure
um
i guess i the fact that you didn't point
out that this is adding uh um
the
fines in here or
you're modifying it i guess i'm having
trouble understanding
um
there's a part in here and maybe someone
we i discussed it with a couple
colleagues
it's talking about if you don't use it
in a vehicle
that's registered to you is there a part
about that
yes
i guess my question is what about the
disabled person who does not drive or a
blind person who does not drive how can
they then have a placard registered to a
vehicle if they don't have a vehicle
because they can't drive when you go to
motor vehicles i believe when you apply
for that
they you have to put down a registration
number
because i i have two plaques
and i had to put down the registration
numbers
follow-up
yeah i'll give you one more one more
so if you have someone who's getting a
ride from someone to a doctor's
appointment they're not allowed to take
their placard
and go into their neighbor's car to get
a ride to the hospital for a i don't
i don't think that should be uh
uh find i mean if you see someone that's
at a hospital or doctor's appointment
it's those that abuse it that
maybe uh someone says oh i got an extra
one here put it on your car and you use
it and you use it all the time
i'll let it go to other people thank you
yeah
representative green yes
all these things that you have
in this bill
are they not already under law yes
so
my question is why do we need this bill
because the abuse of the plaques
well
this bill won't change anything
they'll still abuse it if they want to
abuse it am i right
uh not with the fine up as high as i put
it
well
with all due respect the fines gonna be
kind of these people are on are these
placards temporary or are they going to
be permanent
i believe it's every five years
you have to renew it yeah i know with my
back surgery my knee surgeries i had
temporary placards which lasted about
six months
okay
but in those six months
i could have abused it any time i wanted
to i mean law enforcement takes care of
it i know for a fact that if a placard
somebody is parked in a handicapped
plate with a temporary placard on and
it's expired
if somebody checks it out even in the
store the store can call up the towing
company or police and have that thing
towed out of there never seen it happen
but that's true
well
i have
okay
seeing no weather questions thank you
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee again
uh
we certainly support representative
green in this intent in what he's trying
to do here we also see an abuse of these
types of situations but i just wanted to
offer maybe a point of clarification we
do have a law in the book right now rsa
265 95 subsection 3 that does speak to
obstruction of driver's view
and if an officer does see one of these
hanging plaque cards on a motor vehicle
while in operation he can make a motor
vehicle stop and find the driver for
having that item in its view so as you
alluded to earlier we do already have
that law in place
as far as the fines you know that's a
whole separate object but we also we
also support representative green in
that intent but i believe that that law
is already on the books
to answer your question ma'am from
earlier
the intent behind the hanging plaque
card is exactly what you had said you
can move from one vehicle to the next if
you're a permanent if you are somebody
with a disability you can opt to have
license plates that are attached to your
vehicle so it's there all the time but
the intent behind that hanging plat
guard is so that you can bring it from
one vehicle to another so i'm willing to
answer any questions if you have any
seeing none thank you they're off the
hook again thank you
anyone else who wishes to speak on this
bill
okay seeing none
i close down hb 1158 and we're on break
again
you
all right welcome back everybody um
i'm going to open up the public hearing
on house bill 1214 fn
eliminating fees for walking disability
placards
we have the blue sheets out back for
anybody would like to sign in uh opposed
or in favor of the bill if you wish to
speak please fill out a pink card and
hand it forward
with that chair recognizes
representative telersky the prime
sponsor
thank you thank you mr chairman and
colleagues for the record i am
representative laura tallerski
from hillsborough 35 which is nashua's
ward 8.
today i present to you house bill 1214
fn and act eliminating fees for walking
disability placards
the issue this bill addresses first came
to my attention back in 2020 in the form
of house bill 1547
when then chairman sykes submitted the
bill at the request of the dmv it came
out of this committee ought to pass and
passed the full house on a voice vote in
the middle of the night on that infamous
day march 13
2020. from there it was lost to covid in
the senate where it died on the table
several months ago i had a conversation
with then director bilecki about dmv
requested bills that were lost to covid
and she asked if i could file this bill
again
what this bill does is remove from the
statute on walking disability and
parking placards verbiage that we
actually just discussed at our previous
bill
that payment of a five dollar fee must
be paid to cover the cost for printing
and mailing
these are those hanging placards that
someone gets for a temporary injury or
surgery or permanent placard if they
have a disability
i direct your attention to the fiscal
note on this bill which reads currently
dmv does not charge this fee
as it operates under guidance since it
is needed under the americans with
disabilities act therefore this bill
will result in no new fiscal impact
as it would align statute with our
current practice
in layman's terms
charging a fee for a placard is a
violation of the americans with
disabilities act and the state has not
been charging the fee for the placard
for several years
it is my hope and that of the dmv that
this section can be amended to
permanently reflect reflect current
practice of the department
passage of hb 1214 fn would simply clean
up the statute with no fiscal impact
whatsoever and i consider it simply a
housekeeping bill and with that i'd be
happy to answer any of your questions
thank you
any questions from the committee
this quite honestly could be the easiest
bill of the year i don't want to jinx it
i know what
thank you very much uh i see i have no
other
people signed up to speak
last chance i don't even see anybody in
the room
so i'll close the public hearing on
house i'm sorry i didn't mean that
i know i i figured i'd have a pink card
from you by now so
yeah i'm going to close the public
hearing on house bill 12 14.
um hang on for a moment this could be
okay
all right welcome back everybody
we can uh make efficient use of a little
bit of time
i'm gonna open up the executive session
on house bill 1214 fn eliminating fees
for walking disability placards
chair recognizes representative gagne
for a motion
thank you mr chairman mr chairman i vote
ought to pass on 1214 fn
not to passes the motions are second
seconded by representative thompson
care to speak to your motion
representative
uh
i think representative talersky said it
well uh
they haven't not been the
the mv is not charging this fee anyway
because of the ada
americans with disabilities act so this
put it in statute that they don't charge
thank you sir any further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll assuming she's ready the motion
yes
clerk votes yes representative hill
yes representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative
yes
representative klein knight yes
representative wrong
yes
representative fenton yes
representative rambo yes representative
rich yes representative talaski
representative fox
yes
representative i'm going to kill your
name
hacken phillips thank you heck and
phillip that's a yes
representative
yes
17-0 17.
okay the committee recommendation of
ought to pass
for house bill 1214 fn
is adopted 17-0 is there a motion for
consent so moved moved by representative
any opposed
seeing none consent that is
i'll close the executive session on
house bill 1214
fn
more minutes i think we can probably
squeeze in another one uh give us a few
you
welcome back
i'm going to open up the executive
session
on house bill 1158 relative to the use
of handicapped placards chair recognizes
representative thompson for a motion
uh mr chairman i'd make a motion to uh
itl the bill
okay motions it'll is there a second
second second by representative gagne
did carol speak to your motion
yes mr chairman uh
given that this uh bill is redundant um
it's covered by the obstruction of a
driving mechanism on the current law
there is no real need for the bill
thank you
anybody else care to speak
seeing none
ask the clerk to call the rule as soon
as she's ready the motion is
um itl on house bill 1158
vice chairman
yes
yes representative thompson
yes representative
yes representative ron yes
representative fenton yeah
representative rambo yes representative
rich
representative
yes
yes i'm sorry and my vote is yes thank
you
representative
yes
17.
committee recommendation of ito on
hospital 1158 has
adopted 17-0
um motion for consent moves so moved
moved by representative gagne uh any
opposed
seeing none consent that is
we'll close the executive session on
house bill 1158
next hearing will be two o'clock and
you
all right welcome back everybody um as
our count as the calendar says
we're going to execute a few bills with
some of our free time
after discussion we have time for one
more
i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1150 relative to
the
uh
no that's not true
11.58
i was not wrong 1150 relative to
i didn't ask for is that is there a
motion
check recognizes representative
ankerberg thank you mr chairman
i move uh inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1150.
motion of itl of
index media legislate on 11 50 is their
second represented by second by
representative o'hara
i wish to speak to your motion
thank you mr chairman
as noted in the hearing
this bill has
flaws which prevent it
from being an effective piece of
legislation
um
first of all
the
the purchase of a motor vehicle in
another state um and the attachment of a
registered new hampshire license plate
to that vehicle um
is
not in keeping with our
with other states laws
there's uh
an issue with uh how to validate um a
potential bill of sale
to
authenticate uh when in fact the vehicle
was purchased
among some other issues
and it has since
the hearing come to the attention of the
committee that the department may
actually be
implementing
any further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll when she's ready uh the motion
on the floor is itl on house bill 1150.
vice chairman
yes
clerk ots representative hill yes
representative thompson
yes
yes representative
uh
representative klein knight yes
yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo
yes representative rich
representative talaski yes
representative fox yes representative
representative
yes
17-0 again
i think the committee recommendation of
itl on 1150 is adopted 17-0
uh is there a further motion i would
move consent mr chairman consent
moved by representative gagne anybody
opposed
seeing none consent that is i'll close
the executive session on house bill
1150.
now we have 10 minutes off until our
you
welcome back everybody i'm
being two o'clock i'm going to open up
the public hearing on house bill 1437 fn
relative to registration plates for
and the chair recognizes the prime
thank you mr chairman and members of
transportation
for the record i am representative steve
pearson in rockingham district 6
which is derry and i come before you for
this
past fall i had the fortune of attending
the deerfield fair
and
was
outed as a legislator
and what that did is when i went to talk
to the east coast tractor folks just to
see their display i was inundated by
these guys
over a multitude of problems that they
were dealing with so i spent some time
in
kind of listen to what they had to say
and then i
i actually was invited to a meeting of
the east coast antique tractor club and
went over to kensington and sat down
with them
and i listened
and what i heard was was a was an
interesting problem
i had questions and concerns from those
folks about
various towns and parades on public
streets with their antiques they had
questions in reference
to
whether or not you know they should even
register or not register or display and
i certainly wasn't going to tell them to
violate
the law but the biggest thing that came
to me
was
and it was a very common problem was the
fact that town clerks have a very
difficult time
understanding
antique farm tractors
a gentleman from salem indicated to me
that the town clerk forced him to
register his
75 year old tractor is a piece of
industrial machinery construction
equipment
one clerk insisted because it was a
tractor she made the guy register it as
what we would consider a semi an 18
wheeler which is so
so far from reality it's not even funny
but
that common problem of a huge
misunderstanding of what these were
you know really led me to kind of dig a
little bit and in talking
with with a particular constituent in
derry and i know it's going to sound
shocking but
we are the fourth largest town but we do
still have some active working farms
there
they reiterated kind of the similar
problem in the sense that you know
they're asked well does it have a front
end load loader does it have a back code
as in and that seemed to
matter into them trying to get these
people to register these things as as
construction equipment
so giving it some thought about you know
how do we
how do we take
these antique things that are used
primarily for display in
in historical purposes and how do we
kind of straighten out
this confusion
for these guys to to actually register
this and
you know as someone who owns antique
automobiles it it kind of seemed to me
like a pretty simple solution if we can
if i can register a car as an antique
how come i can't register a tractor as
an antique
so in discussing this with
ols and you know how do we how do we
tackle this problem they said well you
know we can just pretty put much put
farm tractors in with all the other
antiques so
that's pretty much what this legislation
does it
it just adds the
phrase farm tractor into the other areas
of statute as in motor vehicles
motorcycles those sort of things
and puts them into statute as a as a
class of vehicle just like any other
class of vehicle
and as you go through the bill you'll
see that that's
there's no new definitions as far as you
know how we look at things there's no
anything no new references it just
literally adds the farm tractor
in with the antique motor vehicle
motorcycle trailer etc
so the the plan here the goal the hope
is that
in doing so when folks come before their
town clerk
they can simply say i i'm here to
register my antique tractor
and now
all of the rest of these problems go
away
and that is the gist of what 1437 is
thank you
any questions from the committee
representative telersky
thank you thank you for taking my
question how come they can't just
register it as isn't there an
agricultural plate
an agricultural plate to my
understanding would apply to a pickup
truck or an 18-wheeler tractors have
we've had tractor plates in new
hampshire for a long time
um but so they're not considered
agricultural
in under that provision of the law that
that's again more for 18 wheelers in
pickup trucks and things like that
okay
further questions from the committee
representative fenton
uh thank you for taking my question
thank you for being here um
so if i if these were
licensed as a antique tractor vehicle
would that mean i'm
i'm now i'm allowed to drive it more on
the roads so i could use it as a
no um a a farm tractor would hardly be
classified by anyone as a as a motor
vehicle that would you would use to go
get groceries or things of that nature
um
these things i said these are primarily
used for antique display as in
what we saw you know you see at the
deerfield fair and other fairs across
new hampshire um you see them primarily
they'll they may pull a wagon in an old
homes parade or things like that
they're certainly not used for
commercial enterprise they're not
they're so old you would never risk an
antique
you know in that venture anyway and by
putting them into the statute as an
antique
not only do you
have what you could argue is the benefit
of them being in antiques but you also
have the restrictions
so
you know and in discussing that with the
folks
you know they looked at me and said well
this is this is the world we're in
anyway you know again i'm i'm not taking
a tractor built in the 1950s and
doing you know commercial work with it
because the risk of breaking it is just
entirely too high so so this you know
these are
these are by no means you know motor
vehicles
in that sense
okay thank you you also with that
because it is if you want to take a look
uh the restriction he's talking about
look at lines four and five
uh and actually it should be easy to see
how these would comply
for those that don't know this is a huge
hobby in the state of new hampshire it's
actually pretty fascinating
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your time thank you um that's
the
only pink card i have mr obertank you
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee and just to answer a
couple of questions different plate
types
really determine what the use of the
vehicle is so if there's some confusion
out there there's also confusion on what
some of these folks use those
vehicles for but this is pretty clear
that it's not for use in commerce and
it's not to be used on a public way for
everyday use it really does
limit you to a couple of activities
and again the only concern from us is
that somebody's trying to find a cheaper
way to register vehicles which we spend
a lot of our time having those
discussions
that if it's being used for agriculture
and farm use then it doesn't qualify for
an antique plate it has to be registered
as a farm plate
as a farm tractor
and again that comes up to if you're
pulling a trailer down the roadway full
of hay
then you're not in the antique use and
you're in violation
and there are
protocols in play for those things to be
dealt with we can recall plates
administrative hearings police can take
the plates those types of things so
those
barriers are in effect
so safe to say um
and you don't what you you don't have to
but without seeing the pink card which i
still need to by the way
would the department be fine with this
piece of legislation the way it's being
proposed absolutely okay thank you for
that
good
okay
seeing none thank you very much
uh anybody else wish to speak on house
bill 1437 fn
seeing none i will close the public
hearing
and
um we'll have a brief discussion uh if
not we'll see you back at 2 30 for
you
welcome back everyone
uh
we do have time before our next hearing
therefore i'm going to open up the
executive session on house bill 1437 fn
relative to the registration plates for
antique farm tractors
uh chair recognizes representative
ankerberg for a motion
thank you mr chairman
move ought to pass on
1437 fn
motions ought to pass is there a second
i will second that represent me seconds
uh yes quite simply it seems like
there's a need for for this bill um
there is a community out there that um
seems to want this um it doesn't seem as
though that there's much risk of abuse
in terms of the um
you know that there's uh actually
processes in place that uh
distinguish between um sort of the the
show nature of this and parades and
things and distinguishing from
agricultural use
well done sir for yeah for
spur of the moment fantastic further
discussion from the committee
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready motion is
who just came in
i had already had i called the question
unfortunately i called the question so
you're not going to be able to vote you
need to be in your seat but we should be
fine
yes
the clerk votes yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson
yes representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes
uh representative klein knight
yes
wrong
oh okay representative fenton yes
representative rambo
yeah representative rich yes
representative
yes representative fox yes
yes
okay the committee recommendation of
ought to pass on house bill 1437 was
adopted 15-0
is there a motion for consent so moved
moved by representative muser second i
should i think i've forgotten asked for
that a few times
a second on consent
is going to anybody opposed
seeing none consent it is
uh and just to explain what happened for
for those that
aren't sure uh when
you need to be in your seats when the
question is called to in order to vote
we're gonna follow the rules for
everybody not a big deal but that's the
reason you aren't able to okay
uh that being said i'll close the
executive session on house bill 1437
um second it only even made the motion i
yeah today we're gonna do i did get my
amendment
where'd it go oh no i didn't yes i did
yes you do you said you had it yeah i
oh i got the wrong thing i got 1461.
that's what this is
i guess this is for 61. i get the wrong
thing here
we're gonna
we'll discuss this we'll see if we like
the amendment
but if you want to hand that out
you
okay welcome back being 234 i'll open up
the public hearing on house bill 1445 fn
relative to the identification of police
vehicles
as usual if you wish to sign in on the
bill for or against we have the blue
sheets out back if you wish to speak we
have the pink cards please fill them out
hand them forward and we'll get to you
uh all that being said
um
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative trottier
good afternoon good afternoon good
afternoon mr chair and fellow members of
the transportation committee i want to
thank you for your time and
consideration in this bill
i am representative of douglas trottier
district 6 representing the town of
belmont i'm the prime sponsor on this on
house bill
1445-fn
my intent with this bill is to have
police vehicles that are being used for
normal police functions be
fully marked and identifiable
this is for the safety of the public and
the offices themselves across the entire
state
i have seen more
and more of completely unmarked police
vehicles being used for normal police
functions
these vehicles have no visible marking
running regular license plates or also
ghost plates
and running low profile lights in the
front and back windows
this makes it almost impossible for the
public to determine if these are
legitimate police vehicles
these normal functions would include
motor vehicle stops responding to
calls
traffic control or enforcement special
detail enforcement for a
motor vehicle
like dwi speeds and things like that
my concern is citizens are purchasing
retired police vehicles
and driving them daily i have personally
seen some of these vehicles with
spotlights and clear light bars on the
roof and in the windows
these same
they they appear to be as a normal
police vehicle or cruiser although when
asked
the vehicle's owners about the lights on
their vehicles they always say they're
amber however many of these light bars
that are being purchased today have the
capability of changing from amber to
blue
and to red with a flick of a switch
people can order uniforms and badges
online
this makes it harder for the public to
be able to determine if it's a real
across the country there has been an
increase in police impersonators
another concern with the ghost plate
i'm not sure if you're familiar with
ghost plates but these are plates that
are issued directly from the pomodo
motor vehicle
that are almost impossible to trace
by other law enforcement off
offices they cannot just run the license
plate and come up with what department
owns those vehicles or what vehicles
they should be on
so that's why they're called ghost
plates
if there's a complaint made against a
vehicle that has a ghost plate the
agency receiving the complaint must file
a letter with the department of motor
vehicle to obtain
the information on the vehicle
in which department the plate is
registered to
if a complaint is filed on a weekend
say a friday night
the investigation could be delayed
you might hear in the future testimony
that these plates are being used as
undercover investigative tools
so they cannot be identified
however
people in the public cannot just call an
agency and ask them to run a license
plate and get that information
so i don't know why we need these ghost
planes
um
most of the ghost plates are being used
on police
administrative vehicles chiefs captains
and things like that not undercover
vehicles
however
these are the same vehicles that are
being used to stop vehicles responding
to emergency and non-emergency calls
i feel unmarked vehicles with regular
license plates
as i mentioned in the bill itself
some of those will include drug
enforcement
however transparency and visibility is
very important in law enforcement
visibility helps deter criminal activity
and make it easier for the
public to pick out a police vehicle in
the time of need
with these unmarked vehicles with no
identification marks either on the side
a license plate or anything like that
it's difficult
to see it so a citizen might say that
looks like a cruiser when it's actually
a civilian that owns that vehicle that
i had a police chief tell me recently he
drives a fully marked un
mock vehicle from home to work he told
me he travels on i-93 and has
had vehicles past him at i believe 80 or
90 miles an hour
he said
he is able to stop them because they
could not tell
his his vehicle was a cruiser
however i feel that if his cruiser was
mocked
and had the appropriate plate the person
that was speeding would have saw that
and slowed down and that would have
deterred the violation of law
it's not always about
the apprehension it's about
you know deterring the crime before it
happens
i feel that if there's crews that had
the municipal county or state license
plates that are on most
cruises
that would have stopped the problem
actually some states right now
um
i'm mandating um that their vehicles uh
run a
solid blue light when they're just
driving around i saw there's um
scarborough maine that just started
doing that
i believe it's connecticut um state
police
has that capability of running a solid
blue light on their cruises to be
identified easier and also a study has
shown that these lights or the
visibility has
decreased criminal activity
and it has been easier for
citizens to pick out cruises and when
um last session the governor signed into
law the law enforcement
reform bill
which is requiring training transparency
and etc i feel this bill will help
expand the governor's
law enforcement reform bill and make it
safer for everyone
citizens and the um
public
one thing you know i would ask the
committee if this is something they
would consider is after speaking with
some other police administrators is
detectives vehicles
i don't feel they need to be mocked
or run the regular plates because
they're not performing normal police
functions
however if they're going to use those
vehicles
for normal functions you know they're
assigned to a dwi patrol
over a holiday weekend or an enfor a
traffic or a speed enforcement
assignment that the minimum they put on
is their appropriate plate if it's a
state it'll be a
trooper they can put on a state license
plate if it's a county a county plate or
a municipal a municipal plate at least
it shows some
visibility and transparency
[Music]
whereas without those types of plates
there's no identification
at all and
unless a citizen steals one of those
license plates they're
impossible to get by a civilian
after looking at the fiscal note
i see state police said that they have
115 cruises um that do not meet the
requirements of this bill
and they said the it would cost um
316 000
to
bring those cruises up to specs
of this bill
however um
i'm not asking the painting which is
part of the fiscal note for i think
twenty six hundred dollars all i was
asking was the part of the decals which
are 120 dollars
but i do not feel all their cruises need
um these details like i said the
detectives
um
and the administrative that does not
usually go out on regular patrol
they might run into an accident on the
way home or to work
something like that that would be fine i
my goal with this bill is to
show
transparency and visibility
with the vehicles that are out there on
a regular basis i have seen
many many police administrators or
police chiefs in my county alone running
these vehicles that are out stopping
cars on a regular basis
and also working
extra duty in
speed enforcement and in
dwi detection
apprehension so these are the concerns
to me right there i'm not saying every
single cruiser needs to be mocked
as i stated here in the bill itself i
mean the one thing i would ask that if
the committee does
[Music]
feel this is something that we need to
pursue i would ask them maybe for an
amendment adding
and at that point that's pretty much my
testimony if there's any question i'll
be more than happy to answer
thank you any questions from the
committee
i do
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
these uh unmarked cars
i've seen them on the highways
and they are pretty
hard to identify as law enforcement now
these ghost plates bother me
would you be amenable to
still they could still remain stealth
okay
except for
the plates would have to be government
plates
yes i i'm willing to do that
thank you
further questions
i have one if you don't mind
um we have seen this bill before for a
similar similar version of it
and it sounds like you did a lot of
communicating with uh police
you mentioned sheriffs but state police
we did have an issue and did you reach
out to corrections
because the county and the corrections
um
people have a lot of cruisers too many
of them not
and did you reach out to them at all to
see how it might affect them i did not
because i didn't um consider them as
being out on normal patrol
basically
you know the corrections are
transporting you know inmates that are
already being housed in a correctional
facility
they would not be the ones out there
stopping vehicles
they would not be the ones making
contact with the citizens who
are in need of help under most
circumstances i mean if you know a
correctional officer comes across an
accident they might stop to render aid
but other than that no i did not
consider corrections
thank you fair enough actually lions 10
through 12 might take care of that
any further questions
cnn thank you very much thank you very
elizabeth sergeant
representing new hampshire association
the chiefs of police and opposition to
hello
hi good afternoon chairman walsh members
of the committee my name is elizabeth
sargent i work for she infinity capital
group here in concord here representing
the new hampshire association of chiefs
of police
we are in opposition to this bill
i was not prepared to testify
chief obecky was hoping to make it but
he can't so i'm just going to wing it a
little bit
and just read from my notes
that i quickly put together but the
chiefs are in opposition to this bill
one reason being they feel that it is an
unfunded mandate
it says all police vehicles being used
for a valid law enforcement function
shall be fully marked with visible
identifiers it goes on to talk about
adding the agency's name and
on the driver and passenger sides of the
vehicle and just in my notes when we
were talking about it they do feel that
if
a chief of police or an officer is in an
undercover vehicle if they see something
egregious in their job as they're
traveling they do want that ability to
be able to do their job
in a day where they're having a hard
time hiring and
keeping officers it is an extra officer
if they're going about their business
and they see something that's egregious
and the other thing um i was looking
back in some testimony from last year
chief obecky sent a letter to your
committee in january of 2020 um
addressing the incident of false pers um
i'm going to say it wrong
personification
he said he looked since he currently
works for the hollis police department
he did a search of his own records
management system and he said looking
back in 10 years during that time span
he only found one incident of a report
indicating false
personification of a police officer
and lastly in my notes just that
they do oppose the bill they feel that
it would limit their agency from
utilizing the necessary and appropriate
tools to keep our roadways safe
and i'm not sure i'll be able to answer
any questions but i'd be happy to take
any and try to get that answer back to
you for sure thank you
representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman just one quick
question and probably just an email back
would probably be the best way but thank
you could you check if they would be
okay with uh the amendment that
uh vice chairman talked about about
where uh using municipal plates instead
of unmarked or ghost plates yep
absolutely thank you
chair recognizes
is it rusan chester
in support of the bill
how did how did i do by the way pretty
good okay
i don't take it personally my name for
the record is russian chester that's
r-u-s-s-a-n
i am in um support of the spill
i feel that this bill helps protect our
officers and our citizens
i grew up in a time before cell phones
i actually was almost a victim
of someone pretending to be an officer
and having the it looked exactly like a
police vehicle unmarked police vehicle
he had the light that you know you can
put in the dashboard or whatever
fortunately i was aware that there was
not in our state but it was out of state
that i had been made aware of it and he
had come into the state of new hampshire
because we are surrounded by a lot of um
you know a lot of other states
this person had come in he was
representing um as he was
came up to my car as a police officer
fully clothed full police
everything um but because i had heard
that there was a rapist um
that was doing this in new york i chose
not to um
not to give not to open my door he told
me to get out i refused
had i
followed
what most law-abiding citizens would
have done with an unmarked car
i don't know that i'd be here today to
talk to you folks because he also was
eventually found guilty of murder
so that being said in
the era that we have now we have great
technology we have great opportunities
um we tell people you know if you if you
are fearful drive to the closest police
station the bottom line is is that's not
always a reality um people's phones die
uh there's a lot of things that can go
wrong the other thing is is that
there's a lot of situations that i feel
that having the police officers marked
the the officers cars that are being
used for regular um
[Music]
regular
citizen
type of things not undercover not
detectives not
corrections
um but i think it's important that they
are identified um especially times right
now with the way things are everybody is
so worried about what is going on and
what everyone else is doing if we see a
what looks like a police officer
a police office vehicle but they're in
plain clothes
and they don't have any way to know
as a citizen do we really know that
they're an officer
should we really be going up to them and
trying to help them in whatever you know
if they say get out of here or they say
you know do this or whatever should we
automatically just blindly follow
whatever this this person in an unmarked
undercover car is telling us to do
i have significant problems with the
ghost plates
and in closing i would like to say that
i think transparency is really important
especially right now with what's going
on in our state and our country i think
it's even more important for our police
officers and to be given the opportunity
to be as transparent as possible and i
thank you for your testimony would you
take any questions absolutely if there
are any questions from the committee
last person i have signed up to speak
mike comerford from new hampshire state
police
good afternoon mr chair committee
members thank you for the opportunity to
speak here today uh the state police
wanted felt it very important to provide
some testimony today to explain to the
committee members
what we do currently and how we operate
to provide some educational testimony
so that when you're making some
decisions on this bill you'll know at
least from the state police side of
things
how we do things
currently the state police has
approximately 350 police cruisers in our
fleet
230 those police cruisers are marked
state police cruisers those are the
typical ones that you see that are green
and tan they have 360 degree lighting
they have a state police license plate
on them
and they're fully marked with state
police decals
those
those cruisers are primari their primary
responsibility is a traffic enforcement
they're assigned to various geographical
regions throughout the state and they're
the ones that you're probably most
familiar with on our highways
additionally we have approximately 115
other police cruisers same type of
vehicle same type of cruisers they're
just not fully marked like our typical
state police cruiser they're assigned to
administrative staff our command staff
members as well as troopers who work in
our detective bureaus those cruisers are
typically black or silver they'll have a
spotlight on them they have 360 degree
lighting but what they don't have is
they don't have the green and tan paint
job
nor the state police decals on them
those cruisers are issued two plates two
sets of plates they're issued passenger
plates that they use primarily during
their normal duties
and they're also issued state police
plates that are that you typically see
on our mark cruisers it'll say state
police and their cruiser number
those plates are well let me let me back
up a little bit
you know you know
we employ those 115 cruisers those
troopers that those administrative staff
are detectives we employ those troopers
in additional responsibilities
throughout different time periods of the
year so for instance you know
new year's eve we'll ask those
detectives those administrative staff if
they can bolster our patrol numbers if
they can come out and help
and patrol the roadway so when you see
on the news that the state police is out
in full force that's true because we're
utilizing our detectives and our
administrative staff to come out and
supplement our uniform division now when
they do that they're doing it in their
unmarked cruiser they're doing it in
their silver or black car that has 360
degree lighting but at that point per
our policy we make them put on their
state police license plate so it's not
your typical passenger plate so they'll
put on that state police license plate
and they'll go out they'll perform
traffic duties patrol duties dwi
duties they'll assist hampton beach at
certain times hampton pd
or the nascar races just just to name a
few so we we do utilize those cruisers
they're very important to us to bolster
our numbers for public safety
however as this bill is written now
those cruisers do not fall
under the way it's written however we in
the state police would be willing to
work with the sponsor to perhaps come up
with an amendment to this to where we
could
utilize our administrative vehicles our
unmarked vehicles in their current
capacity um
but making sure as we already do that we
do a dog or doing those license plates
when necessary so that they're marked
because if we didn't if we did have to
uh abide by this as you can see there
would be a cost to it
moving forward and but we're certainly
more than happy to work with the sponsor
in that and what i will say uh to those
ghost plates because i actually have one
i have a black cruiser i'm issued a
state police license plate says state
police car four
but i also have a passenger plate number
if you run that passenger plate number
if a local police department runs that
number it comes back to the new
hampshire state police so the new
hampshire state police does
with the exception of our narcotics unit
they do those plates do come back to the
state of new hampshire so with that i'd
be more than happy to take any questions
all right thank you
i'm gonna i have to ask one before i
open it up to the committee
i understand everything you've said
except the you did not mention why you
even need the passenger plates
if you're changing them half the time
when they're assisting in the regular
course of duties but i get that but why
bother changing them why except for
narcotics i understand that one too that
would be the ghost plates in question
why do the rest of the cruisers that are
issued two sets one passenger need them
and that's a great question thank you
for that so the majority of those 115
cruisers are our detective bureaus so
they conduct sensitive
investigations uh they
they do a lot of follow-up interviews
that require going to residences that
of sensitive natures homicides
sexual assaults all
all types of investigations and what we
typically find is when we show up in an
unmarked car with regular license plate
it kind of it puts the victim
if you will more at ease uh
more often than not so a lot of the
times we utilize that to tone down our
appearance which is exactly why
those troopers those detectives are not
in a state police uniform they're
dressed the way i am today
i'm going to grab myself a follow-up
i think i can do this
um
so you're saying the only ones that are
not really
our ghost plates that don't that don't
uh come up as new hampshire state police
plates are narcotics corrupt but all the
other ones do
show up as when when called in new
hampshire state police that's correct
and we actually have the registrations
that are in our cruiser issued by the
dmv director that come back to the state
of new hampshire all right thank you
questions from the committee
correct me if i'm wrong if if you're
stopped by
someone you in an unmarked car with a
spotlight on the door
that presents themselves with a police
officer and you
are skeptical of that particularly with
women
is there
an rsa that allows them to
let the police officer know that they're
going to drive to the
nearest police station or somewhere safe
and
so they can be assured that it is a
police officer
thank you for your question and i can
tell you that that is part of state
police policy if in fact somebody feels
uncomfortable then if and they want to
travel to a nearest lighted area or the
nearest police department we will
accommodate that and we have to abide by
thank you
for the questions representative gorski
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um if i understand
you correctly you mentioned the 115
cruises that are not marked
they do some of these
normal
traffic normal police
functions that the representative
mentioned so it sounds like those would
have to get marked if they're doing
those type of functions
and i guess my question goes at the
the fiscal note of 318 000.
who's on the coffers for that if those
115 cruisers have to be
you know
marked and painted and all that good
thank you for your question it would be
the state of new hampshire when it would
come out of the department of safety's
budget for that
representative o'hare
thank you and just kind of actually a
quick follow-up to that question
if we're just asking for the decals
it would bring the fiscal note down to i
believe like thirteen thousand eight
hundred if it's a hundred hundred and
twenty dollars for decals
so that hundred and twenty thank you for
your question that hundred and dollars
is for
that was priced out for the permanent
decals that are on the um that are on
the cruisers we have in the past tried
to issue out magnetic decals to our uh
to our unmarked cruisers for instance if
they deci if the trooper who's a
detective decides to work an overnight
paving detail out on 93 we had them put
on their state police license plate as
well as magnetic decals however what we
found was the decals weren't holding on
when they were operating the vehicle and
they would peel off and and we would
lose them and they would end up in the
wrong hands
further questions from the committee
representative fenton
thank you for being here and thank you
for taking my question and brad might be
able to help us with this question as
well do you know if there are any any
states that currently do not um that
have to have all their police vehicles
marked
thank you for your question and i
further questions from the committee uh
first times for uh i'll get back to the
second round representative tylerski
thank you for taking my question can you
speak to the issue of um
officer impersonation and if you are
aware of
any um across the state in recent time i
know we we got the reminder from um
the chief from hollis last time said he
knew of one
but
is that a problem
thank you for your question and and i i
do know of two instances
uh we're out on interstate 93 and route
393 in concord because i was the
lieutenant of troop d in concord where
we did have uh
officer impersonations on on two
separate occasions and that was probably
within the last five years
thank you can i have a one quick
follow-up follow-up thank you
um the other issue that i'm just sort of
struggling with is
i guess
if we're if this bill
does go through there are exceptions
here i think i'm reading this correctly
that um it does not apply to police
vehicles being used primarily for law
enforcement functions
involving and then it lists a number
do you
believe that wording is sufficient for
you to still be able to handle what you
need to do
or
does it need more clarification thank
you for your question we would like to
work with the sponsor for more
clarification and the only reason being
our sticking point is because we do use
those 115 other vehicles for what you
would consider normal police functions
at various times throughout the year
thank you
any more questions from the committee
representative hill
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
following up on the impersonation uh
line of questioning earth or thoughts
uh are there any uh suggestions from
across the country of of ways of
handling it other than
that
driving to a lighted area or something
like that is there any way to
to
mark a cruiser
or
or have some technology
available that would identify a police
officer or a cruiser as a police officer
vehicle
i don't know thank you for your question
i don't know of any additional
technology other than i do know that our
new hampshire police standards and
training
and through our police departments in
this state
train on this issue in in because we do
we do have police officers that are that
are driving unmarked cruisers that are
dressed just like i am and they are
trained how to identify themselves for
instance i have a badge i have a id in
my wallet i have a sidearm obviously
and
we are very
keen to that issue which is why
it is the
it is pushed to be aware of that every
time you're stopping a car so for
instance i live in beau
i travel to hazen drive every day
i travel on interstate 89 to 93 to route
393 i have the opportunity to come
across numerous vehicles doing all sorts
of different things and i do take
enforcement action uh more often than
not i'm dressed in a uniform but for
those times that i'm not i'm like this
and i go out of my way
to
identify who i am through an
identification through my badge and
assess the situation if there's at any
point any concerns
i would as we mentioned earlier we would
suggest going to you could follow me to
state police headquarters you could
follow me to concord police department
wherever really would make that person
feel comfortable but i apologize i don't
know of any additional technology that
thank you could fix that
um anybody else who hasn't had a
question yet
representative crawford thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
so um all the unmarked cruisers with
your detectives mike mike oh sorry i'm
sorry so all of your unmarked cruisers
including your detective vehicles are
are they all marked with all the blue
lights and the grill and all over so
that it's not just
a light on a dashboard
thank you for your question and yes they
are they are they adhere to the 360
degree lighting requirement that i
believe was set forth by dot several
years back
they have lights in the grill they have
lights
underneath the headboard
on the windshield they have lights in
the rear dash as well as what we've just
put in in the probably last five or six
years lights on the
passenger side and driver's side mirrors
so that we can
encompass that 360
hello and i degrees know if anybody can
so my follow-up question would be that's
a very expensive um
technology to put into an automobile is
it not would it would someone who wanted
to portray being a a police officer who
really wasn't
would they
would that be an easy thing for them to
acquire or to do to a vehicle
thank you for your follow-up i know i
know for us it's between the uh price
tag of two to three thousand dollars to
outfit our cruisers in uh 360 degree
lighting um so that would be a
significant in my opinion that would be
a significant expense for somebody
um anybody else who hasn't asked a
question yet first round seeing none
representative o'hara
thank you i promise my last question
um i just thought about when mixing his
thoughts with when representing charity
talked about the blue lights in maine
what's your thoughts on running the
solid blue light
thank you for your follow-up i can
specifically speak to that because we do
have the option in our police cruisers
to have a cruise option where you hit
the button and the blue lights stay
on blue constant they don't flash they
just stay blue
what i have found and and we'll often
utilize those during oversized load
escorts and stuff but what i've found
we typically will employ that during
snow storms because it will
get people to slow down
quite frankly
you know we'll patrol the highways we'll
put on our cruise lights and they'll
slow down under normal situations
and again this is my opinion what
happens
more often than not is that it causes
confusion
people will start pulling over when they
don't necessarily need to pull over
because the blue lights are on um and
they're just trying to do the right
thing when it when when we're just doing
anybody else
representative thompson
lieutenant um
i
do you have any awareness of what the
local police and county police with
their unmarked
cruisers might total
i apologize thank you for your follow-up
question i i do not i do not know um
unfortunately i don't know how many
cruisers they have that that would fall
under this category i can only speak to
what we have okay thank you
thank you any other questions from the
committee
cnn thank you very much thank you and i
apologize i didn't introduce myself in
the beginning but my name is mike
comerford and i'm the operations major
with the state police and i've been
there for 24 years and thanks for
covering for me i should have caught
that myself
um last thing too um
there were some good points on both
sides of this and i'm happy to see
when the coat the sponsor prime sponsor
and one of the agencies can get together
please keep me posted in the loop it'll
help me schedule this thing for an exact
session so
with that i'll close the public hearing
unless there's anybody else that wishes
to speak
seeing that i'll close the public
hearing
uh while we're all still sitting let me
give you a little rundown of how this is
going to play out here
uh we do have an executive session
called for uh three o'clock
um
what i'm going to do
i'm going to make just to make a small
announcement about two of those bills
and i'm going to open the public hearing
and recess it so we can have a short
work session on an amendment that you
just received and then when we come out
of the recess we'll open up the exact
session again and we'll take it out of
recess and finish up the other three so
for the record if you're here for house
bill 1100 uh as a courtesy and out of
respect of my ranking member he notified
me that he couldn't make it here today
to defend his own bill after the
schedule was done
i couldn't change it but i don't have to
take it up so we're not going to
for similar reasons house bill 1208 same
thing we will not be taking that up
today either so if any of you are here
to see the exact executive session on
those i apologize for the change uh but
look at next week's calendar uh they are
both
early i believe so we'll have we'll be
making a decision on them next week
uh so that being said if i can see the
calendar for a second what's the first
one on the exact list
except for 1100.
uh
okay
so to keep it official according to
the schedule
i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1461
and i'm going to recess the executive
so
what i want to do
before we we can shut this down for
about five minutes i don't think it'll
take us more than 15. i'm i'm gonna
we're gonna hold a work session on the
amendment for 1461 to see if we're all
on the same page with it if we're not uh
we can then decide to move forward with
an
exec session or not
so just give us five minutes to regroup
here and uh we'll get into that work
session work discussion whatever you
you
all right welcome back everybody sorry
for the delay i just had to get a couple
things clarified
uh something i said earlier i
corrected i cannot do
currently i've got uh the executive
session on house bill
1461 in recess um i cannot do work
sessions on a proposed amendment uh
without being publicly noticed so we're
not moving forward with that uh what we
are going to do i'm going to take it out
of recess
and we're just going to take up the bill
with the amendment in an old fashioned
executive session and see where it lands
so is there a motion on the floor for
so
i'm saying nobody wants to even make a
motion for
1461.
taking one for the team well you can
pick whatever you like
anyway
motion on house bill 1461 fn increasing
uh ought to pass
okay
all right so representatives made a
motion of ought to pass on 1461.
um
is it seconded
we didn't do the amendment represented
by representative crawford
okay this bill is open to further
amendment is there a motion
i will i will also make that motion mr
chairman
on the amendment
uh zero
two eight three h
2022-0283 h is there a second
second by representative
would you care to speak to your motion
on the amendment
give me just a minute to make sure no
problem mr speaker mr mr speaker
anyway
we've all seen littering on the highway
and
according to the testimony that was
given to us
it i think the first offense was
something like 60 some odd
[Music]
and then it increased from there
so this amendment
would says that if any person who
violates any provision of this section
shall be guilty
violation
the fine will go up
from 300
plus penalty assessment for a first
offense and 500 plus penalty assessment
for each subsequent offense
and i think like i see you i hate people
throwing trash out
of their windows when they're driving on
the highway and
i feel they need to be made accountable
so hence the amendment
um
further discussion representativelerski
thank you um
i just wanted to acknowledge some of the
changes that um
came through with this amendment um the
original bill had a
90-day license suspension which is a
number people felt was an extremely uh
extreme
penalty to be
included on this and
someone with the dmv pointed out
that a much more serious offense of um
reckless operation something like that
only had a 60-day license suspension so
i felt that we needed to
bring it a little bit more in line as
much as we want to make a point that
littering is
really not acceptable in our state we
want to make sure that it's in line with
the other uh penalties that we have on
the um
the fine list
and then the only other thing that was
changed that i want to just acknowledge
is that we removed the line that it's a
minimum fine of 300
we've learned through testimony that
when you do a range
such as that for a fine it's very
difficult for both the back end to input
it all into the system and for an
officer to actually decide on what an
appropriate fine is
and it's just much easier to have a set
i appreciate the changes that came with
this
i will say on the record i do think that
the
fine amounts are a little bit high but i
would much rather see something go
through
that um does increase the penalty so i
will be voting for the amendment
thank you i'll i'll just add uh the
other change from the original bill
uh the first draft with the original
bill i should say did not mention
penalty assessments which are the fees
for administration uh costs so those
were also added in the amendment
did you have a question representative
thank you so much chairman i just want
to go on the record just to say that um
i we're we're we're trusting um our
very
amazing police force to
um
give tickets out to people at their
discretion
and um i'm hoping
that this won't disproportionately
affect the most vulnerable and
less wealthy amongst us
and and with that uh thank you
thank you
anybody else
in closing i'll just say this
i live in southern new hampshire do a
lot of commuting every year
i actually witness a lot of littering
and i think it's reprehensible uh when i
heard it was 62.50 for first offense for
littering
i i looked at this bill a little bit
differently and said you know what maybe
this is does does bring it more in line
i'm happier with the changes
with this amendment
so i will be supporting it
thank you i we don't necessarily need a
roll call
for the amendment but i think in this
case it would be wise
so we'll when the clerk is ready we'll
call the rule
on amendment two uh zero two eight three
uh
vice chairman gagne
yes uh clerk votes yes representative
hill
yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg no
representative gorski yes
sure
uh representative tillerson
yes
sorry it's okay representative
ryan
yes
representative fenton yes
representative rambo yeah
representative rich yes
representative fox
yes
representative hacken phillips yes i
feel so good about that representative
value yes
and chairman walsh yes
okay
sixteen one okay the amendment zero two
eight three h uh is adopted did you say
sixteen sixteen to one
uh the motion on the floor was out to
pass now becomes ought to pass as
amended um
i'll ask the question to make it
official are there any other amendments
it is open for further amendment
okay seeing none motion on the floor is
ought to pass as amended any further
discussion
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll once
again motion on the floor is ought to
pass as amended
yes
no
representative fox
yes
so
the committee recommendation of art to
pass as amended is adopted 16-1
this is an early bill i presume it'll be
going to ways and means
that being said i don't believe it can
go on consent
but i'll ask the question after the fact
is there any opposition from the
committee if i can get it on consent
excuse me mr chair yep i'm
um it's my understanding that bills that
have a fiscal note cannot go and consent
i don't believe it can which is what i
said okay but i figured i would see
because it is still pretty low uh what
that cut off is in his second committee
i'm 99 sure it won't be on console okay
uh but i just figured i'd give myself
that one percent chance that we can get
it there and make things simpler in
session okay
so
okay um so that being said i'll close
the public hearing on house bill 1461
fbn
so if you give us a couple minutes to
reset we have i think one more that we
can do maybe two
yep
you
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome back
one i did not open uh the executive
session on this would be house bill
1464.
uh with some
some continued discussion on this uh i'm
not going to take it up today we'll
bring i will reschedule this one for
next week as well which means that's the
end of our work today
um anybody that owes me a report please
if you can get it to me before you leave
that would be greatly appreciated like
you say i'm still chasing
three of them from last week
and just to know where you're at the
bills that we've moved off from today to
next week are all early we have we're
going to take care of them next week one
way or the other
the deadline for
second committee bills has been pushed
forward because of
session constraints
so that being said thank you very much
everybody we get a lot done today
and we'll tackle the remainder of our
early bills
next
tuesday
in the future too we had 39 bills
overall
today makes uh we heard 20 of them so
far
i'm gonna try to continue well we've got
tuesdays so the next two tuesdays we'll
probably do nine bills a piece
uh and there will be two standing and
that'll be the ones that are going to
require a room larger than this
um
on the fifth tuesday so that's that's my
tentative plan but please always look at
the calendar to confirm it but tuesdays
are the days so with that thank you very
you